Sag Kinder, hier wird es jetzt ernst. Lisp, Tückel, Täuschung, Irreführung, Unterbinden von Nachrichtenwegen und Spionage sind schon seit Anbeginn der Menschheit bediebte Mittel der Kriegführung. Mit dem Hereinbrechen des Informationszeitalters und dem Ende des Kalten Krieges kamen die vom akuten Feindbild mangelgeplagten Strategien der US-amerikanischen Teilspreitkräfte auf drei Erkenntnisse, die ihre Apparate ins nächste Jahrtausend hinüber retten sollen. Zum einen stellten sie fest, dass die USA dank durchgreifenden Einsatzes von Informationstechnologien das verwundbarste Land der Welt sind. Zum anderen befinden sich aber auch Armee und Wirtschaft potenzieller Feinde in immer größerer kritischer Abhängigkeit von Computern, Datennetzen und hochentwickelter Elektronik. Die dritte Erkenntnis war, dass zukünftig nicht mehr große, hierarchische, mit Atomwaffen ausgerüstete Armeen der Feind sein werden, sondern eher netzwerkmäßig strukturierte Organisationen wie Konzerne, Drogenkartelle oder Rebellenstreitkräfte. Daraus entstand die Idee, die bisher getrennt marschierenden Zweige der psychologischen Kriegsführung, elektronischer Kriegsführung und elektromagnetischer Waffen unter dem Oberbegriff Information Warfare zusammenzufassen. Verschiedene Interessenten aus so unterschiedlichen Ecken wie den Geheimdiensten, der Armee aber auch gänzlich unbeteiligte, wie der ehemalige Rock-Empressario Vince Schwartau, begannen als sogenannte Experten die Öffentlichkeit mit haarsträubenden Visionen von Horden, Hackender, Anti-Amerikaner zu beeinflussen, die als finale Aktion alle wesentlichen Rechner des Landes mit elektromagnetischen Bomben lahmlegen und so die Supermacht USA unter den Willen irgendeines Islamisten-Scheiches zwingen. Um den größten Verwundbarkeiten vorzubeugen, sollen schnellstens einige Milliarden Dollar für die Sicherung der nationalen Infrastruktur bereitgestellt werden. Nachdem die entsprechenden Horrorszenarien auch in den gängigen Wochenblättern ausführlich gewürdigt wurden und die einflussreicheren Senatoren von der heimischen Rüstungsindustrie vom allseitigen Nutzen des Aufbaus offensiver und defensiver Info War Kapazitäten überzeugt waren, war das Geld bald bewilligt. Vieles von dem, was jetzt als neue Waffentechnologien präsentiert wird, wurde schon seit den 80er Jahren unter dem Etikett SDI entwickelt. Insbesondere die Grundlagen für elektromagnetische Waffen mit und ohne Atomsprengsatz entstammen den Star Wars Forschungsprogramm. Die hübsche Illusion, die sich mit dem Begriff Information Warfare verknüpft, ist, dass niemand mehr in einen Krieg erschossen wird. Ob das nun stimmt oder nicht, das berichtet jetzt Chaosradio.
Ich bin wie ein Eel, ein Roller, 8 in 1, Huda. Ich bin gespannt, was sie sagen. Ich bin gespannt, was sie sagen. Ich kann Geld verdienen oder alles in der Zeit bekommen. Denn nach dem Wunsch beginnt mein Rhein flügelnd. Wenn ich es mache, ist es das Schicksal. I wasn't too high to know what I was doin. So we went together, blazin the jeeper. If I'm the fool, yo, I'll do the same, she must love it, she ain't never complain. Don't moan, she's kicking, I like screaming, I'm working so hard, and she's much steaming. She's my freak, y'all, but she's no skater.
Jiba Jiba, Tonlock ist das aus seinem 88er Album.
Locked After Dark.
So, jetzt kommt erstmal der übliche chaotische Mikrofontest.
Mikrofon?
Welches Mikrofon?
Super, Andi.
Ganz großartiges.
Andi probiert gerade alle Mikrofone. Du hast ja hier nur einen Kopfhörer auf. Also bei dem einen Kopfhörer auf jeden Fall. Nein, da geht der laut sprechen. Dann musst du den abnehmen und du kriegst das Mikro hier. Ja, weil sonst, wenn der Kopfhörer offen ist, piept es sonst. Dann sieht der viel sportlicher aus.
Dann muss aber erst die Lampe leuchten, oder?
Jetzt leuchtet das Lämmchen.
Frank funktioniert, Tim funktioniert, haben wir gerade schon gehört. Frank, Andi und Tim heute vom Chaos Computer Club hier. Herzlich willkommen. Genau, die Notbesetzung.
Wieso die Notbesetzung? Es gibt da einige Umbesetzungen wegen Umzügen. Es ist ja nicht schlimm, wenn es nicht immer 16 sind.
Andreas, du brauchst nicht mehr zu kommen. Wobei wir eigentlich viele schöne Beispiele geben könnten zur informellen Kriegsführung. Wir könnten hier alles erzählen. Man kann uns ja nicht sehen.
Wir könnten hier sagen, wir sind zu sechst. Zu siebt.
Wir sind ja auch zu sechst, aber das haben wir eigentlich keine erzählt, wenn du es nicht verratest. Aber die Hauptfrage ist doch, warum ist Johnny denn heute eigentlich nicht da? Wollte er denn nicht eigentlich kommen? Wir haben doch diese tollen Sprachaufzeichnungen, die wir letztes Mal gemacht haben und dann durch den Computer gejagt haben. Klingt auch wirklich verdammt gut. Ja? Wer ist denn da? Nein, nicht F1.
Man fragt nicht F1.
Die Clone-Sendung habt ihr nicht gehört, ne? Wo wir Kutmer geklonet haben und nur aus dem Sampler hier immer haben abstehen lassen.
Gehört Radio?
Mann, echt?
Echt, welchen Sender?
Ich hör jetzt übrigens wieder Radio. Ach echt? Ja, ich hab aufgehört Fernsehen zu gucken. Und deswegen muss man in Erzberg so ein bisschen was anderes tun. Radio ist sowieso das beste Medium. Ja, aber ich hör bei Deutschlandfunk. Ich mein, stell dir die Situation hier, mir egal, wenn ich auf der Autobahn bin, hör ich total gar an Deutschlandfunk.
Da erfährt man mal was.
Dezent und keine Werbung.
Genau, dass die Desinformation so seriös verpackt ist.
Ähnlich wie bei uns, da erfährt man auch eine Menge bis 1 Uhr hier Chaos Radio, der Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Information und Desinformation, was heißt informelle Kriegsführung? Da gibt es im Proben zwei Bereiche. Der eine Bereich und über den wollen wir heute gar nicht reden. Wir wollen heute versuchen, darüber nicht zu reden. Wir wollen jedenfalls nicht über rein technische Angriffe auf Informationsinfrastruktur reden, also irgendwelche Bomben oder Kabel schneiden oder was auch immer. Wir wollen eigentlich über die Benutzung von elektronischen Kommunikationsmedien reden, um vielleicht nicht so ganz wahrheitsgemäße Realitäten zu vermitteln. Da geht es also um diesen alten Spruch, Wissen ist Macht, oder?
Ja, das geht es darum. Wir wollen halt irgendwie versuchen, anhand von vielen vielen Beispielen...
Hör mal auf zu blättern, Andi, das hilft doch jetzt eh nicht mehr.
Herr Müller, wir müssen diese Sache aus dem Kopf, das brauchen wir nicht vor vier haben.
Das muss jetzt nicht jedem so. Jetzt regt euch doch mal den Finger in den...
Zensur-Taste drücken. Also, worum es uns heute geht, ist, wir wollen mal versuchen, darzulegen, wie Mächte auf dieser Welt versuchen, mit Hilfe von Macht über Medien, mit Hilfe von Informationsmanipulationen, mit Unterdrückung von Informationen, mit Informationen, die teilweise wahr, teilweise nicht wahr oder nur selektiert wahr sind, versuchen Menschen zu manipulieren, um Dinge zu tun, für die man früher Bomben schmeißen musste, oder für die man früher Leute umbringen musste. Warum möchte ich da definitiv über die eigenen...
Vollends anschließen? Nee, ich muss Frank da einfach wieder sprechen. Es geht nicht um die Versuche, sondern es geht darum, wie sie es machen.
Ja, aber wir haben sie doch enttarnt, Andi.
Haben wir dann.
Genau, morgen ist es aber Schluss.
Morgen geht das nicht mehr. Und dann wird endlich alles gut. Im Hintergrund hört ihr Musik von einem Künstler, den wir mal Sabatinen nennen. Genau, in der Mangelung eines anderen Manns, aber auch eine Kontribution zu unserer Sendung. Wir haben übrigens auch eine Einsendung für unseren Jingle-Contest bekommen. Ja, mehrere. Die ZIP, die gekommen ist, konnte ich nicht lesen, weil mein ZIP-Laufwerk kaputt gegangen ist. Und ich kann sie nicht lesen, weil ich keine Haare habe. Ich werde das auftreiben. Da diese Sendung.
Da die Sendung wieder zurück versprochen, die Frage ist nur, wann.
Da diese Sendung nur einmal im Monat stattfindet, nämlich jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, ich hätte die ganze Zeit gedacht, wir haben nächste Woche. Ich dachte auch.
Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat.
Ach mein Gott, bis ich mich da eingewählt hab. Da gucken sie lieber einen Kalender. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat ist hier Chaosradio, wie gesagt heute ein politisches Thema, kann man so sagen. Ja, kann man sagen. Übrigens auch immer jetzt Chaosradio, du weißt. Genau, ihr könnt die Sendungen, die hier gelaufen sind, dann ein paar Tage später nehme ich an, das dauert ja immer ein bisschen. Soweit ich weiß, macht Lutz das sofort. Echt? Das müsste also im Prinzip dann, sobald ich das gelingt habe, morgen dann sozusagen über unsere Webpage abrufbar sein. Also Lutz ist da immer sehr schnell und sehr beschäftigt und da freuen wir uns drüber, denn ihr könnt die letzten drei, vier Sendungen auch schon drin. Wir haben die letzte Sendung in Re-Audio, wir haben diverse Sendungen noch als MPEG 3, die habe ich aber noch nicht auf dem Webserver. Aus was weiß ich für welchen Gründen. Und dann ist auch noch eine Januar Sendung von einem Hörer in Re-Audio kodiert worden. Schau an, schau an. Wollen wir mal gucken, vielleicht kriegen wir den Rest auch noch zusammen.
Aber das Interesse ist relativ groß.
Übrigens auch nach den Files, die wir letztes Mal gespielt haben, die Windsongs 95, die stehen auch immer noch auf dem Web-Server. Den Leuten, die das mit FDP ziehen wollen, mit den kleinen Happys kann ich bisher noch nicht helfen. Aber da wird man vielleicht auch erstmal beim Thema. Ich wollte nur kurz zur Einführung nochmal sagen, für alle, die es jetzt vielleicht zum ersten Mal hören, die können sich auch ein bisschen Background-Information über diese Sendung holen im Netz. Natürlich bei fritz.ww.fritz.de oder am besten bei chaosradio.ccc.de Und diese Adresse ist auch das, wo Tim immer die neuesten Sachen postet und so. Die Seite wird immer schöner, finde ich. Das weiß jeder, dass das eine schwane Arbeit ist. Und wenn man zusätzlich auch noch Geld verdienen muss, dann ist das immer besonders erstaunlich, wenn da tatsächlich aktuelle Sachen drauf sind. Finde ich zumindest. Auf meinen Seiten ist nie was wirklich Aktuelles.
Doch jetzt ja, aber egal. Normalerweise nach einem halben Jahr.
Jetzt bleibt es wieder ein halbes Jahr so liegen. Information Warfare, das Thema heute im Chaosradio. Vielleicht gibt es erstmal einen Fritz-Kurz-Info, den Fritz-Information-Warfare sozusagen. Und danach gehen wir direkt rein in die Geschichten.
So sieht das aus.
Diese Desinformation wurde Ihnen präsentiert von... Hopscotch heißt der Song, ist ein neues aus dem neuen Album von Howie B. Turn the Dark Off heißt es. Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermühen wächst, dann 100, 1. 22.31 Uhr.
Befreiungsaktion. Nach sieben Stunden hat die Polizei am Abend eine Geiselnahme im Gefängnis Berlin-Tegel unblutig beendet. Ein Sonderkommando überwältigte den Geiselnehmer, der am Nachmittag eine Justizangestellte in seine Gewalt gebracht hatte. Die Frau konnte unverlässt befreit werden. Einigung in der Serbischen Republik in Bosnien finden im Winter vorgezogene Wahlen statt. Darauf einigten sich heute Präsidentin Plavzic und das serbische Mitglied des Staatspräsidiums in Parlek-Reifnik. Damit soll die seit Monaten schwelende politische Krise innerhalb der serbischen Staatsführung beigelegt werden. Müllentsorgung. Nach Angaben von Greenpeace existiert ein internationales Netz zur illegalen Entsorgung von Atommüll und anderen Giften ins Mittelmeer. Daran beteiligt sind allein in Italien 26 Unternehmen. Rede. Außenminister Kinkel hat die Reformbemühungen von UNO-Generalsekretär Anan unterstützt. Vor der Vollversammlung der Vereinten Nationen bekräftigte Kinkel zugleich den Wunsch Deutschlands nach einem ständigen Sitz im Welt-Sicherheitsrat. Johnny, mach bitte den Sport. Fußball. In der zweiten Hauptrunde des DFB Pokals gab es folgende Ergebnisse. VSC Stuttgart, Hertha BSC 2 zu 0, Leverkusen Hamburg 2 zu 1 nach Verlängerung, Reuterfüür, Dortmund 2 zu 4, Hannover 1860, München 2 zu 1, der Brückenkaiser Flautern 0 zu 4, Neppen Stuttgart Afrika 4 zu 1, Ulm Mainz ebenfalls 4 zu 1 und Mannheim Jena 3 zu 4 im Elfmeterschießen. Jetzt Wetter. Nacht 8 bis 4 Grad, morgen wieder überwiegend sonnig, Temperaturen bis 20 Grad. Ab 10 Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Dreieck Spreeau und Niederlehne, Sperrung der rechten Fahrspur, es kommt zum Stau und Stadtverkehr Berlin-Tiergarten. Die Entlastungsstraße ist zwischen der Straße des 17. Juni und der Tiergartenstraße gesperrt. Der Grund ist eine Ölspur auf der Fahrbahn.
Gattgatter Heinrich mit dem Fritzkopf-Entwurf.
Nein.
Reiter 31.
Oktober in der Kultur Brauereisen präsentiert von. Genau.
Und hier ist Radio, Chaosradio auf Ritz. Mit Information Warfare als Thema, informelle Kriegsführung, Chaos Computer Club weiß Bescheid.
Hoffentlich.
Ja, eines der hübschesten Beispiels für informelle Kriegsführung oder Information Warfare, weil es gibt eigentlich keine schöne deutsche Übersetzung, ist, was die Amerikaner gerade in Jugoslawien treiben und zwar geht ihnen da ein bisschen auf den Krieg, dass die Serben mit ihren Radio- und Fernsehsendern eine ziemliche Stimmung gegen das Dayton-Abkommen machen. Und um die Sache zu unterbinden, ohne da gleich wieder Raketen und Bomben schmeißen zu müssen, haben sie halt entschieden, zwei EC-130 Electronic Warfare-Flugzeuge dahin zu schicken. Das sind drei. Diese Flugzeuge haben die Fähigkeiten, Fernsehsender vollständig zu stören, sodass er nicht mehr zu empfangen ist. Genauso mit Radiesendern und haben gleichzeitig noch einen richtig kräftigen Fernsehsender an Bord, um halt eigene Programme anstelle dieses gestörten Kanals lenden zu können. Und der Effekt ist halt, sie können praktisch einen Kanal ausschalten und ihn sofort übernehmen. Das heißt, man sieht dann drei oder vier Sekunden Rauschen und dann geht es halt mit genau demselben Programm weiter. Nur man weiß halt nicht, dass es halt jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie Radioserben-Terror ist, sondern halt irgendwie Radio-NATO-Terror.
Das machen die vom Flugzeug aus.
Das machen die vom Flugzeug aus und das haben sie auch schon in Panama in großem Maßstab eingesetzt, als sie da den Neujäger, glaube ich, da rausgeprökelt haben. Da haben sie das halt gemacht, um die Bevölkerung halt massiv zu desinformieren, was mal eigentlich passiert. Also die Leute wussten tagelang nicht, ob sich was los ist, weil halt kein Radio, kein Fernsehen mehr ging. Das halt irgendwie noch irgendwie die Wahrheit berichtet hat, sondern Arad war irgendwie im Wesentlichen darauf ausgerichtet, halt irgendwie Konfusionen zu verbreiten.
Aber ich meine, die Stationen selber müssen das ja mitkriegen, dass sie nicht mehr selber senden.
Ja klar, aber sie können nicht dagegen tun, weil ihre Frequenz halt platt gemacht wird. Und zwar mit einer Leistung, die halt so hoch ist, dass man halt im Regelfall nichts mehr empfängt, außer vielleicht im unmittelbaren Umfeld der Sendestation.
Sind demnach dann nur die Amis, die sowas haben?
Also die Amis sind die einzigen, die zugeben, dass sie sowas haben. Also die elektronischen Kriegsführungsabteilungen der Bundeswehr haben sowas mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit auch, um es halt im Ernstfall zu verwenden. Aber die Amis sind die einzigen, die da echte Einsatzerfahrung haben. Die haben halt auch richtige Fernsehprofis da geheuert, die halt tatsächlich in der Lage sind, dann auch ein amtliches Fernsehprogramm zu machen, was nicht so aussieht, als ob der GI. Joe irgendwie am Schlittpuls sitzt. Und haben halt auch diese Fernsehprogrammgeschichten, die sie da fahren, auch irgendwie lange mit ihren Psychologen ausgeknobelt. Also die wissen schon, was sie da tun. Also die Russen haben ähnliche Geschichten in Tschetscheni gemacht, eigentlich nur mit Rundfunksender, man ist es nicht mit Fernsehsender, die sie halt gestört und überlagert haben und haben dann halt eigene Programme gesendet.
Nur ist das Übernehmen von Medien eine ganz alte Geschichte. Die moderne Version ist Tettel-Abwurf. Ja, da sind davon auch Radio-Stationen, das ist ja das große politische Interesse auch daran, zum Beispiel das Radio-Stationen, da gab es ja auch in der deutschen Geschichte einige Geschichten.
1, 6.
Das sind jetzt die ganz wenigen Teile, wo wir es so ganz direkt festmachen können, genauso wie Chaosradio jetzt vielleicht den Dendazist übernommen hat, es hat ein paar Stunden, da hat die Amerikaner irgendwie was platt gemacht und was übernommen, aber das ist ja nicht der normale Prozess, der normale Prozess.
Das ist aber auch ein Versuch, zumindest eine richtige Information, das auszusprechen. Du kannst uns ja nur desinformieren. Genau. Also die interessante Geschichte dabei ist, dass wir mittlerweile technisch soweit sind, dass die Übernahme dieses Mediums nicht mehr wirklich festzustellen ist von unbeteiligten Zuschauern. Also es ist halt nicht so wie früher irgendwie im Osten, dass man halt irgendwie Lord of the Five-Töne während der 100, 6 Nachrichten hatte, weil die irgendwie nicht wollten, dass irgendwie die Nachrichten mit Tum Tum Tum Tum Tum irgendwie schon wieder 4000 Ostler nach Tschechien ausgebüxt anfangen. Dann haben sie die halt irgendwie mit FifeTone überlagert. Sondern ist halt so, dass sie halt ihre eigenen Nachrichten senden und ihr eigen Programm fahren. Und das ist schon doch ein erheblicher Unterschied gegenüber einer sichtbaren Störung und Überlagerung der Programme, wie sie halt bei allen anderen normalerweise...
Na gut, aber andere Radiosender wie Voice of America haben sie dann doch einfach vom CIA betrieben. Und da brauchen sie nicht irgendwie groß zu hören. vom eigenen Land aus.
Also wenn du halt einfach Fritz hörst und jetzt machst du so... Und dann sitzt da halt irgendwie ein Chaosradio und erzählt halt irgendwie Scheiße, dann, naja, kann man halt nichts mehr dagegen tun. Und möglicherweise würden wir es wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal mitbekommen. Das ist schon eine deutliche neue Qualität.
Ob wir überhaupt noch was mitbekommen? Anja hatte zwei schlechte Tage, entschuldigen Sie sich. Also du, was du jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen möchtest, und da hast du ja auch nicht ganz unrecht, ist, dass das nicht jetzt wirklich der Information Warfare ist, worüber wir jetzt eben gerade gesprochen haben, auf den wir eigentlich hinaus wollen. Der eigentliche Information Warfare ist halt wirklich die gezielte Kriegsführung und zwar eben auch mit der Qualität einen wirklichen Krieg abzulösen. Ja, also ich denke, es geht ja nicht um die Kriegsführung. Vielleicht gibt es ja noch Leute, denen noch nicht ganz klar ist, warum das so wichtig ist. Vielleicht kann man dazu vielleicht auch noch mal ein, zwei Minuten fragen. Gut, und dazu kann man eben das wollte ich ja gerade kurz anführen. Also insbesondere die amerikanische Regierung hat ja eine sehr schlechte Erfahrung im Vietnamkrieg damit gemacht, dass sie eben nicht die Hoheit über die Bilder hatten, sondern dass da eine Menge Journalisten rumgehobt sind, Bilder gemacht haben, Reportagen gemacht haben und so fort. Und die amerikanische Bevölkerung sehr wohl im Bilde im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes war über das Elend, was so ein Krieg produziert und sozusagen die hauseigene Propaganda, warum man also diesen Krieg führen muss und dass man da für frische, junge Soldaten braucht, aus der Bevölkerung zu akquirieren sind und so weiter und so fort, dass das eben nicht gegriffen hat und dass die Amerikaner im Wesentlichen den Krieg sozusagen im eigenen Lande verloren haben, nämlich den moralischen Rückhalt der Regierung zu stärken, diesen Krieg überhaupt zu führen. Und insbesondere aufgrund dieser Erfahrung wird ja jetzt das Thema Medienhoheit, also die Macht über die Information, die Macht über die Bilder und die Texte, die über Geschehnisse berichtet werden. Das ist ja eigentlich das Thema, denke ich, wo informationelle Kriegsführung, das kann man dann so bezeichnen, aber ist Marketing nicht auch, ist nicht auch, wenn wir so Werberahmenprogramme haben, wenn uns irgendwelche Werbung ins Hirn gedrückt wird und das getan wird als Geschichte, ist das auch schon Kriegsführung, ist das nicht Kriegsführung gegen uns als Menschen? Also deswegen, also den Begriff, wo fängt Krieg an und wo hört Krieg aus, den will ich eigentlich nicht diskutieren, sondern was wird mit Informationen, mit manipulierten Informationen bewirkt? Das denke ich ist...
Also diese Geschichte mit dem Kontrollverlust in Vietnam über die Bilder, die liegt Ihnen noch echt auf dem Herzen. Also bei so einer Information Warfare Konferenz, wo Anja und ich waren, da gab es halt so einen Typen, der berichtet da halt irgendwie schockiert darüber, dass demnächst irgendwelche Medien ehemalige Spionageflugzeuge aufkaufen und halt irgendwie da richtig Hightech reinstecken, um halt irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Kriegsgebieten unabhängig berichten zu können. Und sie diskutierten dann halt ziemlich ernsthaft, wie man halt irgendwie da Verhinderungstaktiken fahren kann und die Dinge halt nur kurz jammt oder abschießt, um halt zu verhindern, dass halt die Medien unabhängige Bilder halt vom Ort des Geschehens bekommen. Und im Golfkrieg war es ja so, dass sie da halt tatsächlich die Sachen, wie sie sich zukünftig die Berichterstattung von Kriegen vorstellen, deutlich voranzutreten haben.
Also da haben sie es wirklich geübt, sozusagen. Allerdings sind ihnen da auch ein paar Sachen, also auch die Gegenseite hat da natürlich dazugelernt. Nicht nur Saddam Hussein war immer schön ordentlich gekleidet, aufgetreten und so weiter und so fort, sondern es gab insbesondere einen Fall, der dann später zu einem kleinen parlamentarischen Nachspiel geführt hat. Und zwar gab es ja die Geschichte, dass die Soldaten, die irakischen Soldaten, die da sozusagen einmarschiert sind nach Kuwait, dass die also nach Augenzeugenberichten auch Kinder vergewaltigt haben, also unmittelbar dort, wo sie einmarschiert sind, irgendwie Babys aus den Brutkabinen in Krankenhäusern rausgeschlossen haben und all solche minderschönen Dinge. Und der Trick war der, dass es dazu eine Anhörung im amerikanischen Kongress gab, also im Weißen Haus, wo eben eine Augenzeugin auch explizit davon berichtet und unmittelbar danach war eben die Senatsentscheidung, ob jetzt der amerikanische Starter sozusagen eingreift in diesen Krieg. Und die Entscheidung war nur mit, was weiß ich, mit sieben Mandaten, also sozusagen sieben Stimmen Mehrheit, waren die da früher. Hinterher stellte sich heraus, dass die Augenzeugin, die von diesen angeblichen Vergewaltigungen berichtet hatte, die 15-jährige Tochter des kuwaitischen Botschafters in Washington war und dass diese ganze Geschichte mit den irakischen Soldaten, die also da Kinder vergewaltigt haben soll, eine Kampagne war, die von der kuwaitischen Regierung über eine PR-Firma, über eine Firma, die heißt Hill & Nolthorn, arrangiert war, um also da ganz gezielte, bestimmte Stimmungen zu machen. Diese Geschichte wird hier berichtet von einem Menschen, der heißt Chuck Decaro, ist Präsident einer Firma, die heißt Aero Bureau. Das ist eine recht ausführliche Dokumentation, die ich hier habe über den Golfkrieg im Rahmen einer Information Warfare Konferenz, die in Washington im August letzten Jahres war. Ich glaube, vor genau einem Jahr. Und da geht es also um die verschiedenen Bedeutungen der Macht von Bildern, was die also bewirken können und was... Das große Problem, das man als Person damit natürlich hat, ist, welcher Information traue ich denn? Das ist doch eine eigentlich völlig subjektive Entscheidung von mir, oder? Wenn ich CNN anscheite und einfach für mich entschieden habe, CNN sagt meine Wahrheit, dann ist das so und wenn ich auf so einer Konferenz fahre... Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist schon höher. Es geht ja einfach darum, dass du... Also ich meine, wir können dir ja auch nicht sagen, was die Wahrheit ist. Wir können ja hier noch versuchen, ein paar Mechanismen aufzuzeigen. Ich habe auf einer anderen Konferenz, da ging es im Krisenperl, eine andere sehr schöne Geschichte. Die lernt sich auch nochmal deutlich macht, dass da eigentlich, also was sich auch Konzerne dieser Mechanismen bewusst sind, dass es nämlich an allen Flughäfen auf diesem Planeten im Grunde genommen es ein paar Eimer Farbe und ein paar Pinsel gibt, damit wenn ein Flugzeug zum Beispiel mal über die Landebahn hinaus schießt und irgendwo in ein Gebäude rein rast oder nicht rechtzeitig hochkommt, ist auf irgendeinen Grund in Minenunglück auch ein Flughafen, gibt eine Entführung oder irgendwas. Das heißt allererst, dass das Logo der Fluggesellschaft vom Flugzeug gepinselt wird, damit um Himmels willen kein Bild in die Presse kommt, also danach werden die Rettungsmannschaften gerufen und so weiter und so fort, aber dass es einfach verdammt wichtig ist, dass kein Bild in die Presse kommt, wo du einfach ein Flugzeug siehst, das in der Mitte durchgebrochen ist oder wo blutige Leichen rumliegen oder was auch immer, das dann assoziiert ist mit dem Logo einer Fluggesellschaft, wo dann eben Lufthansa oder was auch immer daneben steht. Und dass die schon sehr genau wissen, was sie da tun. Es gibt gleich noch ein paar mehr konkrete Geschichten und konkrete Beispiele für die informelle Kriegsführung vom Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio.
So, jetzt hatten wir auch gerade noch schön die übliche Musikdiskussion.
Tim bringt immer gerne neue deutsche Welle mit und ich bin dann immer so ein bisschen am Nase rumpfen und sag, ach Tim, der alte Kram und so, aber du verwendest damit natürlich ganz was ganz anderes als ich. Ja, ich mein, die Diskussion, jetzt haben wir richtig geklättet, spielen wir noch gar keine neue deutsche Welle, aber es kommt halt noch so ein bisschen. Ja, so, kann das nur nochmal bekräftigen. Das ist halt Musik der frühen 80er Jahre und irgendwie aus dieser Zeit ist ja eigentlich auch diese Hacker-Szene entstanden. Also es gibt ja zwei Seiten der neuen deutschen Welle. Es gibt da dieses, ich geb Gas, ich will Spaß und irgendwie alles ist toll, das ist im Prinzip nichts anderes als was heute Blümchen heißt. Aber der eigentliche Ursprung liegt halt wirklich in diesem langsamen, auszusteigen beginnenden Leuten der 80er Jahre, die irgendwie diesen aufblühenden Kapitalismus schon nicht mehr ertragen können. Und wir werden es nachher hören, ich möchte ein Eisbär sein. Eisbären müssen die weinen so im kalten Polar und dann müsste ich nicht mehr schreien, alles wäre so klar. Das ist halt irgendwie schon der erste Einstieg gewesen in den Cyberspace. Und dieses irgendwie alles da draußen interessiert mich nicht. Ich bin jetzt hier in meinem Terminal und ich hab den Login und ich bin jetzt drin im Netz und dort lebe ich und dort existiere ich. Ich bin halt ein Teil der virtuellen Gemeinschaft. Aber für die Charts haben wir ja dich.
Ja, aber nicht nur für die Charts.
Prodigy ist auch nicht so tolles Album, weil diese Nummer finde ich sehr klasse.
Aber Tauidi Album ist auch für die Charts.
Aber ihr habt noch mehr Oldies, die ich dir nerven kann. Wenn ihr zweiter streitet, dann packt es meine Lala ab.
Eine der Plätze, die besonders abhängig und empfindlich sind für Informationsmonipulation, ist natürlich die Börse. Die Börse lebt von Gerüchten, von kleinen Geschichten. Da werden Nachrichten, die woanders niemand interessieren, zu Großstürzen ausgebauscht. Da gab es in den letzten 1, 5 Monaten solche Geschichten an den asiatischen Währungsmärkten, dass plötzlich die Währung der aufstrebenden asiatischen Tigerstaaten ziemlich in den Keller gegangen sind aufgrund von massiven Spekulationen. Die Regierung von Malaysia hat daraufhin den George Soros, einer der größten Währungsspekulanten, den wir auf diesem Planeten haben, beschuldigt, dahinter zu stecken und diese Währung manipuliert zu haben. Und zwar mit dem Hintergrund, dass George Soros, mit der Kohle, die er da über hat, verschiedene Gesellschaften finanziert, die sich um Menschenrechte kümmern, um politische Freiheiten usw. Er hat eine Gesellschaft, das ist das Open Society Institute. Die sind auch relativ gut finanziert und kümmern sich z.B. auch um Boma, also über Myanmar, wie jetzt der neue Staatsname da ist. Und in Boma steht es mit den Menschenrechten, wie wir alle wissen, nicht so besonders gut. Und die machen da eine ziemliche Kampagne gerade. Und die Asien, was die Vereinigung von diesen asiatischen aufdrehenden Staaten ist, hat nun gerade Boma aufgenommen in ihre Gesellschaft, wogegen dieses Open Society Institute mächtig protestiert hat. Und naja, nur lag halt der Schluss nahe, wenn der George Soros so ein Institut finanziert, dann kann es auch gut mal sein, dass er dann aus der Frust, den halt mal so richtig eine vor den Deckel gibt und halt ihre Währungen in den Keller bringt. Natürlich hat Soros debattiert und hat gesagt, er kann halt nichts dafür und das ist halt nicht sein Ding. Aber Fakt ist, dass halt da die Währungen alle richtig in den Keller gegangen sind und selbst wenn die Information nicht stimmt, man weiß ja nicht, ob es stimmt, führt sie doch zu erheblichen Verspannungen. Das ist halt wieder so ein Beispiel für beidseitige Informationsmanipulationen.
Wobei das Ganze mit einer anderen kleinen Geschichte, mit der ich jetzt wieder aufwarten darf, im Grunde genommen auch viel einfacher geht. Eine Geschichte, die sich vor etwas über einem Jahr in Deutschland abgespielt hat. Da wurden von einem, ist ja auch Schnurr, ist das vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit, auf unseren Planeten in einem Land, da wurden von einem Düsseldorfer Hotel Telefaxe verschickt mit Briefpapier der Firma Fokker, das also besagte, dass der erwartete Unternehmensverlust der Firma Fokker für das vorausgegangene Jahr, wo jetzt also die Bilanz mittlerweile erstellt war, doch höher ausfiel als erwartet. Diese Telefaxe ging an verschiedene Börsenzeitungen und so weiter und so fort, woraufhin Fokker an den Aktien dann etliche Prozentpunkte gefallen ist. Die Firma Fokker selbst hat das Ganze, da sie die Faxe nämlich nicht verschickt hat, erst acht Stunden später ungefähr bemerkt und war dann erst in der Lage, entsprechende Korrekturmeldungen mit ihren korrekten Milanten und so fort rauszuschicken, sodass sie dann natürlich an der Börse wieder ihren normalen Kurs irgendwann hatten. Der Trick besteht einfach darin, dass jemand massiv Fokker-Aktien gekauft hatte, nachdem die Dinge an der Börse gefallen sind, also zu vergleichsweise günstigen Kursen und dann eben von dieser Korrektur wieder profitiert hat. Aber gerade an der Börse ist das dann nicht ein richtiges Spiel für alle möglichen Leute, so viel Information rauszunehmen? Was passiert denn, wenn mich jemand dabei erwischt? Also mich sowieso nicht, aber denjenigen erwischt, der diese Focker-Faxe rausgeschickt hat? Na, derjenige, der das ausgeschickt hat, der wird sowieso nicht erwischt.
Fälschung von Dokumenten?
Da muss man schon ein bisschen trottelig sein. Übler nachsehen vielleicht, aber so blöd, sich damit erwischung zu lassen, ist doch keiner. Das ist doch viel zu einfach. Fax fälschen ist, weil das ist Pippi-Fax. Nein, nein, der Trick ist ja, die Gefahr an der Passe besteht ja vielmehr, dass du damit erwischt wirst, dass du da irgendwelche Aktien kaufst oder keine kaufst. Aber das kannst du eben auch geschickt über Treuhänder, Banken und sonst wie alles abwickeln, sodass das erst wirklich untersucht wird, wenn du da richtig massiv Kacke machst. Also für so ein paar Millionen Mark dreht sich da keiner irgendwie die Dinger rund. Gibt es noch ein paar Geschichten, die vielleicht nicht gleich an die Börse gehen, weil das ja doch immer so ein Feld ist? Also für mich ist das immer so ein Feld, ich denke da blicken sie gesund durch. Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen weit weg, aber Telefax-Gerät ist denke ich relativ... Wir hatten vor einem Jahr schon eine schöne Telefax-Geschichte, die passt hier vielleicht ganz gut rein. Um vielleicht noch mal klarzumachen, wie gerade das Telefax-Gerät, der mittlerweile akzeptiert ist, Kommunikationsgerät wunderbar für Dessenformationen, diverse Zwecke missbraucht werden kann. Wie gesagt, ich glaube, wir hatten die Geschichte schon mal, aber es durchaus wäre das zu wiederholen. Da gab es mal Phone-Freaks, das weiß schon, das sind die mit dem PH-Freak, Jungs, die halt gerne kostenlos telefonieren und die immer auf Telefonnetze losgehen und alle möglichen Verfahren rausfinden, solche Leitungen zu bekommen. Ein sehr schöner Trick ist dabei, sich einfach von einer Telekommunikationsfirma unter einem bestimmten Zugangskurs einfach einen Ferntrank freischalten zu lassen auf Kosten einer anderen Telekommunikationsfirma, die davon am besten überhaupt keine Ahnung hat. Und sehr beliebt im Fernleitungsmarkt schilenische Telekommunikationsfirmen, weil in Chile vor einigen Jahren so dramatisch privatisiert wurde, dass es dort mittlerweile Zustände gibt, dass mehrere 20, 30 Telekommunikationsfirmen Fernleitungswege anbieten. Und die aktuellen Tagestarife für diese Leitungen werden sogar in der Tageszeitung veröffentlicht. Und die Leute sitzen dann morgens irgendwie an ihrer Telefonanlage und programmieren sozusagen ihre Telefonanlage dementsprechend. Und eine dieser Firmen war nun ein Opfer von Phone Freaks, die da einfach angerufen haben und gesagt, ja, hier MCI USA, wir brauchen mal ein paar Trunks von euch, wir haben da irgendwie einen Engpass. Ja, kein Problem, schickt uns ein Fax. Tja, das haben sie dann auch gemacht. Fax zu fälschen ist eine einfache Sache. Es gibt ja viele Leute, die meinen, mein Fax wäre sicher, da steht ja die Nummer drauf. Nur diese Nummer wird eben auch von dem Faxgerät generiert. Wenn man mal ein Faxmodem gehabt hat, dann merkt man, dass man da sowieso alles selber eingibt. Also man kann den vollständigen Inhalt dieser Seite eben selbst komponieren und es gibt nicht in dem Telefonnetz etwas sicherstellt, dass das Fax auch wirklich von daher kommt, was drauf steht. Also die haben halt MCI-Fax zusammengepackt und bitteschaltet und Fankleitung frei. Und jetzt kam das Problem, die Bestätigung dafür, dass die Leitung freigeschaltet war mit dem entsprechenden Freischaltungscode, der sollte eben auch zurückkommen per Fax. Und nun ging das also nach Chile und als Absenderadresse haben sie auch tatsächlich eine amerikanische Telefonnummer angegeben. Das war ja wichtig. Nur, dass eben diese Telefonnummer nicht MCI war, sondern eine Phone-Freaker-Mailbox in den USA, die nichts anderes machte, als unter dieser Nummer auf den Anruf zu lauschen. Und auf der anderen Seite hingen dann die Jungs aus Deutschland, die dort angerufen hatten und in dem Moment, als die Chileinnen einfach zurückgefaxt haben, wurde es einfach durchgeschaltet und das Rückfax kam dann halt in Deutschland raus. Dann hatten sie halt irgendwie für ein paar Wochen ihre freie Leitung, bis MCI dann irgendwann gemerkt hat, dass sie da irgendwie 100.000 Dollar zahlen, für etwas, was sie nie bestellt haben. Also auch da zeigt sich eben, wie einfach es möglich ist, die falsche Information in die Welt zu setzen, um seine persönlichen Interessen durchzudreppen. In diesem Fall halt Hacker, aber genauso gut. Mittlerweile bedienen sich ja die Geheimdienste der gleichen. Chaosradio der Computer-Bemut bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club im Studio und mit Join Me an den Reglern und mit dummen Zwischenfragen. Natürlich wollen wir nicht nur, dass ich dumme Zwischenfragen stelle, sondern ihr könnt das auch tun. Und da das Thema informelle Kriegsführung ist, Information Warfare, könnt ihr zu diesem Thema anrufen. Ihr könnt entweder Fragen stellen oder ihr könnt eure eigenen Erfahrungen mit Informationen und Desinformationen beschreiben. Also sowas muss man ja nicht nur an der Börse erleben, sondern sowas erlebt man im alltäglichen Leben. Seid ihr schon mal selber Opfer von informeller Kriegsführung geworden? Im kleineren Sinne vielleicht. Oder die nächste Frage, was glaubt ihr überhaupt noch?
Die Fritz-Hotline ist gechangelt.
0331 für Potsdam. 74 81 110. Welchen Medien vertraut ihr denn?
Kein Medien. Interessanterweise hat statistisch gesehen diese Radio noch die höchste Glaubwürdigkeit von allen Medien. Nein, die BBC hat dazu eine lange und breite Studie gemacht. Sie haben halt einfach dieselben Nachrichten-Testgruppen vorgelegt, übers Fernsehen, übers Radio und in der Zeitung. Von diesen Nachrichten waren halt etliche falsch und etliche wahr. Und in der Statistik kam hinten raus, dass das Radio, egal ob es nun falsch oder wahr war, die größte Glaubwürdigkeit von allen Medien hatte. Die Leute glauben.
Das heißt ja aber nicht, dass das glaubwürdig ist, sondern das heißt, dass die Leute angehen, dass das glaubwürdig ist. Also ich glaube, ich glaube, man sollte sowieso nicht glauben. Das Medium, den ich am meisten, wie soll ich sagen, also Glaubwürdigkeit schenke im Sinne, dass ich davon ausgehe, dass die Information vielleicht stimmt. Das sind Dinge, die ich auf dem Internet finde, aber auch nicht beliebig, weil man ja auch dort diversifizieren muss. Ich glaube, eigentlich der Quelle immer nur dann überhaupt etwas, wenn sie möglichst nah an der eigentlichen Quelle liegt. Also am besten die Quelle selber. Also der Direktgrad zur Quelle. Also es gibt eigentlich einen Satz, dass auf dem Punkt, wozu einer guten Information gehört, eine gute Quelle. Und überhaupt zu einer Information gehört eine Quelle. Falkst du uns ja auch immer schön ein. Ja, das ist auch eine unbedingt wichtige Indoktrination, wenn man in irgendeiner Form auf diesem Tandem sinnvoll auf Realitätskonstruktion aufbauen will, die auch einen gewissen realen Anteil haben sollen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es Medien, denen wir überhaupt nicht vertrauen.
Wofür kann man schon mal sagen.
Ja, hier ist der Jörg aus Berlin. Ja, eins möchte ich zur Begriffsklärung nochmal deutlich machen. Information Warfare und informelle Kriegsführung, wie es jetzt im Deutschen übersetzt wurde eben, das ist ein kleiner Unterschied. Das Wort informell wird im Deutschen eigentlich anders gebraucht.
Moment, informell oder informationell?
Er hat gesagt informelle Kriegsführung und das stimmt nicht ganz.
Das ist richtig. Also eigentlich sind das die deutschen Termine. Informationelle Kriegsführung wird...
Krieg mit Informationen oder wie auch immer, damit sollte man das belassen. Informell ist eigentlich aus dem Soziologiebereich, das sind so lockere Kontakte zwischen Menschen.
Alles klar, mein Fehler. Also informationelle ist das richtige Wort, Ben?
Oder informationelle ist. Der Krieg der Ideen oder wie auch immer. Aber informell ist anders gemeint im deutschen Sprachraum.
Also direkt übersetzt heißt es Informationskriegsführung.
Aber auch das greift irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Jörg, warum beschäftigst du dich damit näher?
Das war mal ganz früher, früher, früher. Ich war mal bei der Armee. Ein Offizier und da hatte ich mit sowas auch zu tun.
Gibt's da ein paar, gibt's da auch eine Geschichte zu? Ich mein, wann war das, wann war diese Zeit?
Ich war 76 bis 90.
Und da war das natürlich auch schon ein Thema.
Na ja, das war ja mein Beruf. Oder bestand ein meines Berufes.
Und was hast du da gemacht?
Ein Offizier war ich.
Ich meine, habt ihr jetzt gezielt an der Verbreitung von Desinformationen und an Techniken zur Verbreitung von Desinformationen gearbeitet oder habt ihr euch in erster Linie um das Herausfiltern von möglichst wahrhaften Informationen gekümmert, oder in welchem Rahmen?
Also ich persönlich in meiner Tätigkeit hab sowas nicht in der Praxis gemacht.
Also gelogen haben die anderen.
Ich bin dazu ausgebildet worden und hab auch die entsprechenden Fähigkeiten, oder hab die Fähigkeiten gehabt, ich hätte das auch machen können in der Praxis. War aber nicht gefordert auf diesem Gebiet.
Das heißt, ihr habt das nur geprobt sozusagen? Kannst du das ein bisschen beschreiben, wie man so was probt?
Naja, das erste, man muss einfach noch mal wissen, dass wir im Prinzip einen Krieg der Systeme hatten, oder wie auch immer man das jetzt bezeichnen mag, oder Kampf der Systeme, oder wie auch immer. Und die erste und wichtigste Übung war, dass man regelmäßig mit entsprechenden Informationen aus der Bundesrepublik West-Berlin ausgewertet hat erst mal.
Du warst bei der NVA? Aber er hat doch Armee gesagt.
Nicht Wehr.
Das hab ja sogar ich gemerkt.
Ich bin hier der Wessi.
Also mit anderen Worten, bei euch ist die in Anführungsstrichen richtige Information aus dem Westen angekommen. Und ihr habt dann geprobt, wie ihr die filtern müsstet, um sie weiterzugeben.
Das haben wir nicht geprobt. Die sind richtig gefiltert worden. Und verdichtet worden. Und dann sind dann entsprechende, weiß ich, aus 100 Zeitungen sind dann fünf DIN-A4-Blätter entstanden. Das ist der Hauptinhalt, der heute in Tagesereignisse wie auch immer so wie in der Bundesrepublik dargestellt wird. An die Bodenleitungsinformationen und alles so eine Dinge. Für die höheren Offiziere. Ich war aber bei den Grenzgruppen gewesen. Und diese Dinge hab ich vor allen Dingen während meiner Studienzeit gemacht an der Akademie in Dresden zum Beispiel.
Sag mal, wenn man jetzt diese Information so aus erster Hand hat, also selber das einfach weiß, wenn das für einen nicht nur eine Geschichte oder ein Gerücht ist, sondern weiß es, wann man es selber gemacht hat, wie machst du denn das heute? Welchen Informationsquellen glaubst du denn?
Ich geheule ja nicht mehr.
Das ist das Resümee, was hier gezogen wurde vom Chaos Computer Club.
Ja, also das hat ein paar Jahre gedauert, aber das ist also, was soll ich denn 35 Fernsehsendern, die hier im Kabel oder 30 oder 33, was soll ich denn da noch loben? Ich bin doch ja nicht immer in der Lage, selber irgendwie da was zu filtern.
Dann kannst du dich noch an irgendeine Geschichte erinnern, die er damals als richtige Desinformation enttarnen konnte?
Ne, als Desinformation...
Es gab ja so ein paar grobe Geschichten, wo der Rias behauptet hat, dass die Butter knackt wird und die Leute dann in die Kofferle gerannt sind, und sich Butter gekauft haben, dann war das tatsächlich knackt. Das waren ja so die Sachen, die halt im Kalten Krieg da so liefen, die gegenseitigen Spielchen. Und hätte sein können, dass du noch ein paar Geschichten...
Also, ne, so was... Mit so was hab ich mich eigentlich auch nie beschäftigt. Das war auch nicht unser Problem in der Armee. Oder bei der Grenztruppe.
Okay, ja, vielen Dank.
Ne, ich hab noch eine andere Geschichte. Da ja der Computer Club Chaos Dings da dran ist jetzt mit. Hab ich richtig verstanden, ja? Das ist ein großes Thema. USA und Bundeswehr und Bundesregierung und wer auch immer das Informationen macht. Wir müssen die Geschichte insofern ganz klein bisschen natürlich auch umdrehen. Sagen wir mal einfach ganz grob gesagt, die große Hacker-Szene in der ganzen Welt betreibt diese Spiele natürlich auch. Mit ihren Methoden und mit ihren Mitteln, die sie haben, was?
Die Hacker-Szene, was ist denn die Hacker-Szene?
Ich sage es einfach jetzt nur mal so, Frau Scharwitz, es ist einfach.
Also es gibt ja nicht die Hacker-Szene, es ist schon so, dass die Leute natürlich auch alle ihre Spielchen spielen sollen.
Ja, genau. Also jeder möchte irgendwie auf seine Art und Weise...
Ihr seid doch hier die Stimme der Wahrheit.
Ich war erst letztes Wochenende auf eurer Homepage gewesen, habt mir angeguckt, ich habe nichts gegen euch. Hacker und hab nichts gegen ihre Mentalität und gegen das was zu tun. Mehr kann ich dazu auch nicht sagen.
Das ist durchaus berechtigte Ansage.
Lisa, direkte Frage an CCC. Hacker-Szene ist ein weiter Begriff, aber bei euch jetzt intern, würdet ihr sagen, ja, da spielen wir auch mit? Wir sind uns natürlich durch die Beschäftigung mit diesen ganzen Themen ein bisschen der Mechanismen bewusst. Da wir natürlich auch bestimmte Anliegen haben, wie z.B. Informationsfreiheit, wie z.B. die Leute ein bisschen kritischer gegenüber den Informationen zu machen, die sie aufnehmen, benutzen wir natürlich ganz subversiv-offensiv, wie wir nun mal sind, diese Techniken dazu, um genau das zu bewirken. Nämlich, um dann kein bisschen Bewusstsein zu schaffen.
Oder zumindest versuchen wir das.
Also ich meine, ob wir das tatsächlich tun, das ist dann irgendwie eine andere Frage. Aber abstreiten würde ich das nicht.
Das Motto unseres nächsten Kongresses ist, alles ist erlaubt. Genau, und vielleicht ist das ja ein ganz gutes Abschlusswort. Gibt uns Gelegenheit, vielleicht den Chaos Communication Kongress schon mal frühzeitig anzukündigen. Genau.
Wir werden dieses Jahr wie immer den Chaos Communication Kongress durchführen. Das ist jetzt schon der 14. in Folge. Und er wird wieder in Hamburg stattfinden, Hamburg-Eile steht. Der Chaos Communication Kongress, für die, die es nicht kennen, ist eine dreitägige, friedliche Kongressveranstaltung, die immer am gleichen Datum standfindet, nämlich am 27. 28. 29. haltet euch fest, Dezember. Also direkt zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr in Hamburg-Eile steht. Informationen dazu findet ihr auch auf unserer Homepage, die wir ganz nachher auch nochmal durchgeben. Wir werden auch dieses Jahr wieder viele verschiedene Vorträge von Experten, natürlich auch von Hackern, also aus der Szene heraus, aber auch externe Leute haben. Und wir haben uns eben dieses Jahr aus bestimmten Gründen das Motto nichts ist wahr, alles ist erlaubt gewählt. Wie gesagt, nicht ohne Hintergedanken.
Vielleicht können wir da später nochmal drauf eingehen.
Ja, und nochmal Aufruf an euch. Ruft uns an, 0331 für Potsdam, 748110. Bei den ganzen Geschichten, die ihr jetzt gehört habt, schreckt man natürlich erstmal ab und sagt, ich hab keine Bomben oder keine Börsen oder Kriegsbeispiele hier vorzutragen. Es kann ja auch sein, dass ihr einfach nur Fragen habt. Wie laufen denn eigentlich bestimmte Informationswege ab? Zum Beispiel, ich hab das neulich mal jemand auf einer Praxis gefragt, wo kommen eigentlich die Nachrichten her, die oft durchgesagt werden, wie funktioniert das? Ich meine, das ist überhaupt keine unberechtigte Frage. Wo kommen sie her? Na, wo kommen sie her? Von den verschiedenen großen Pressestellen, also DPA, wie heißen die anderen? Reuters. Hier gibt es einen Computer, der ist angeschlossen an diese Pressestellen. Die geben verschiedene Schlagzeilen mit den zugehörigen Meldungen raus und das sieht so aus, dass man einen Rechner vor sich hat, auf dem, ähnlich wie in der Newsgroup, die Oberthemen stehen und die rasen rein. Also diese Meldungen kommen mit verschiedenen Prioritäten. Und vor euch im Flur sitzt dann immer dieses wohlausgefragene, kompetente, journalistisch gebildete Personal. Vorhin meinte übrigens jemand zu mir, den schieb ich öfter in der Zeitung, als ihn aber in keinem schon interessiert. Jedenfalls kommen diese Nachrichten wirklich mit ziemlicher Geschwindigkeit rein. Also je nachdem natürlich, wie die Lage gerade ist, rund um die Uhr findet man da mehrere Themen. Das ist natürlich nach Themen geordnet. Dann gibt es Prioritäten, also besonders wichtige Nachrichten haben die höchste Priorität. Man sieht das dann auf dem Bildschirm auch. Und das muss dann gefiltert werden von einer Nachrichtenredaktion, die nach besten Gewissen dort sich hinsetzt und sagt, das ist für unsere Hörer wichtig oder das ist unwichtig. Und ja, so kommen dann die paar Nachrichten von diesen vielen Hundert, von diesen vielen Tausend, die täglich hier eingehen, an eure Ohren.
Und deshalb noch der Prozess, wie halt irgendwie die Nachrichten in den Nachrichtenagentur generiert werden, der ist nämlich noch mal viel subjektiver.
Das ist ja dann wieder eine Frage an euch, finde ich, weil das weiß ich natürlich überhaupt nicht. Hallo, wer ist denn da dran? Hi, wer bist denn du?
Der Martin aus Belsig, hi.
Martin, hallo, hast du eine Frage oder eine Geschichte zu erzählen?
Ich wüsste es nicht, vielleicht eine Frage.
Was ist deine Frage?
Information, es geht um Information, oder?
Ja, im weitesten Sinne. Hast du ein bisschen zugehört vorher? Ja, ein bisschen.
Dann hören wir noch ein bisschen zu.
Genau, ich höre zu.
Nee, das ist heißt Advanced Technology. Das ist aber ein Sampler, den kriegt ihr nur bei, wie heißt das da, am Ringensufer Hardware. Also das ist ein Direct-in-Power-Talk heißt der. Zeig mal. So richtig schöner, richtig finsterer Drum'n'Batman. Ist das echt? Das wird hier noch bestimmt auf andere kleine Läden. Das kann sein, aber ich hab in Berlin zumindest nur dort gekommen. Schön, wieder was dazugelernt, siehst du? So, Francois ist am Telefon, hi.
Ich hab mal eine Frage.
Was passiert eigentlich mit den ganzen Informationen, die so einzelne Menschen anfallen? Die dann irgendwo, zum Beispiel bei Banken und so weiter. Jedes Mal wenn ich eine Kreditkarte benutze, da lasse ich doch eine deutliche Spur, was ich wann, wo gegruft habe.
Da haben wir auch vor ein paar Monaten schon mal, das ist nämlich deine sogenannte Datenschleimspur, die du hinterlässt und da hatten wir auch schon eine ganze Sendung extra drüber. Diese Informationen werden natürlich benutzt.
Ja, aber das ist ein...
Wenn du Geld hast? Nee, so auch nun nicht, aber wenn du noch...
Du kannst sie dir kaufen. Vielleicht haben wir die Real Audio Sendung, demnächst auf dem Server, dann kannst du dir die vielleicht anhören, da sind eigentlich alle Fragen beantwortet worden. Wenn du einen Internetzugang hast, hast du einen?
Kennst du jemanden, der einen hat?
Da kann ich jedenfalls davon ausgehen, dass auch deine Kreditkartendaten, die du hinterlässt, deine Datenspur, die hinterlässt, gegen dich verwendet werden kann. Wie jede bessere Aussage. Also, ich verliess immer eine Aussage damit, wenn du irgendwas irgendwo reinsteckst. Also würde ich jetzt wirklich die Sendung wiederholen, weil es natürlich ein sehr komplexes Thema ist. Aber prinzipiell hinterlässt du diese Spur und die kann benutzt werden. Nicht von jedem, also nicht von mir jetzt unbedingt, aber von anderen Banken, von anderen Firmen und so weiter. Also die Sache, die wir vor der Sendung haben, haben wir darüber diskutiert, wo wir jetzt irgendwie den Begriff Information Warfare abgrenzen und wo nicht. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie versucht zu sagen, gut Marketing oder was Firmen machen mit persönlichen Daten, das passt jetzt nicht ganz rein. Da könnte man sagen, okay, natürlich führen auch Kriege, irgendwie werden auch gegen Menschen geführt, damit sie Produkte kaufen, Werbekriege. Aber das passt sozusagen leider nur bedingt. Diese komische Telefonabschaltgeschichte, wenn jemand nicht redet, das dann immer so zugeht, wenn jemand nicht laut genug redet oder so.
Habt ihr euch mal wieder so eine Telekom Anlage gekauft?
Ich hab doch keine Ahnung, was hier ist.
Hier ist die N-Teile mit der Wählscheibe. Mit Rosafrömm und Telefonhöhre?
Genau.
Mördreiter 1 für Patzan 74118110 ist unsere Nummer. Wer ist denn da? Hallo.
Moin, Ricardo hier.
Moin, Ricardo.
Folgendes, der Begriff zum Crime Against Humanity. Also in der deutschen Übersetzung wurde das ja in den bürgerlichen Medien zumal als verbrechend die Menschlichkeit genutzt. Das ist ja die Doppelbedeutung von Humanity auf Menschheit und Menschlichkeit.
Na ja, heißt das nicht mehr Mankind?
Nein, ich denke in so einem......Hochbegring nach? Okay, und in welchem Zusammenhang steht das jetzt? Ja, ich denke, dass durch die Besetzung von Begriffen auch so eine Desinformation stattfindet.
So eine Desemantische Kriegsfrau. Der Begriff, den Begriff gibt es tatsächlich. Also in einer normalen Politik ist es ja so, dass Politiker versuchen, Begriffe möglichst weit am Vorfeld zu besetzen, um halt irgendwie damit Meinungen zu bilden. Das ist irgendwie praktisch genau dasselbe wie...
In Englisch gibt es zum Beispiel die schöne Unterscheidung zwischen Security und Safety. Und in Deutsch lässt sich einfach dafür immer nur das Wort Sicherheit finden, sodass hier irgendjemand von Sicherheit redet. Eigentlich keiner so genau weiß, was jetzt eigentlich gemeint ist. Also soll jetzt irgendjemand gesichert werden? Oder geht es sozusagen um seinen Bonus? Oder geht es hier...
Ich kann mich selber entspüren.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Safety und Security? Security ist irgendwie so ein technischer Übergriff. Und Safety ist eher Sicherheit im Sinne von...
Na, Safety mehr.
Na, wenn jemand mit etwas Safe... Ricardo, Unterschied zwischen Safety und Security?
Scheinbar nicht.
Security ist für mich eher so ein technischer Begriff. Und Safety ist auf Menschen bezogen.
Ja, aber was uns in Deutschland, also Tim und ich, ziemlich unabhängig voneinander aufgefallen war irgendwie, damit sie auch wirklich sicher sein können, war halt irgendwie so dieser finale Werbeslogan, der dann plötzlich überall war.
Genau, es war alles, Blumentöpfe, Shampoo und sicher wieder grüne Daumen.
Und damit die Begriffe noch mal sauber und sicher zu definieren. Es gibt, um nochmal kurz um diese Informationsverfälschung zu kommen, da gibt es auch so ein paar Begriffe, wo denn von den Leuten, die also professionelle PR machen, Public Relations, also sozusagen die Kunst, die Öffentlichkeit, davon glaubhaft zu machen, wovon man sie irgendwie glaubhaft machen will, da gibt es zum Beispiel eine Unterscheidung. Wenn bei einem Unternehmen, sagen wir mal, bei einem Chemieunternehmen fällt irgendwie was um, da passiert irgendwas, da gibt es drei Kategorien. Das eine wäre ein Problem. Ein Problem ist, da fällt einmal Wasser um und da sind jetzt irgendwie 5 Liter Wasser weg und das muss irgendwie aufgewischt werden. Also ein Problem ist eine Sache, die überschaubarer ist, die einsensbar ist, die behebbar ist, die keine Folgen nach außen hat. Das ist also für das Unternehmen erstmal kein Problem. Eine Katastrophe wäre es zum Beispiel, wenn da jetzt aus irgendeinem Tanklastwagen irgendwie Öl dann entläuft oder da nochmal eine Giftgaswolke irgendwie vom Bergsgelände in eine Wohnsiedlung strömt.
Da gibt es vielleicht irgendwie verletzte Tote.
Das ist schon eine echte, also da kommt ja dieser Begriff Katastrophe. Das ist also über das Werkgebiet hinaus. Der Name des Unternehmens wird womöglich mit den Ereignissen in Verbindung gebracht. Das ist nicht schön, aber da gibt es zum Beispiel so eine kleine Regel, die da lautet, nichts ist kürzer als das öffentliche Gedächtnis. Also überhaupt kein Problem, wenn mal einmal sowas passiert. Und dann steht das ein Tag in der Zeitung und nächsten Tag steht da wieder das Lady Die gegen einen Betonpfeiler und der Chauffeur, der sich jetzt noch erinnert an das Protokoll und überhaupt. Also wenn da so Sachen dazwischen kommen, ist das alles kein Problem. Das sind alles so überschaubare Geschichten, was denen aber echt Sorgen macht. Und da gibt es in der Tat jetzt nicht nur eigene Erteilung, sondern auch eine eigene Wissenschaft für sogenannte Issues. Issues sind also Sachen, die, ich weiß auch jetzt keinen deutschen Modus, wie gesagt, hier Angelegenheiten. Angelegenheiten, also so Sachen, die immer wieder auftreten. Zum Beispiel Produkte, die aufgrund einer bestimmten Eigenschaft immer wieder so zu Problemen, zu Unbehagen führen, wie demanipulierte Lebensmittel. Oder Winderwahn zum Beispiel. Winderwahn ist auch so eine Sache, das ist ein Issue. Das ist ein Thema, das kommt immer wieder. Und dann gibt es das sogenanntes Issue Management. Also da werden solche Unternehmen, die zum Beispiel Produkte herstellen, die so kleine Probleme haben, so Allergien auslösen oder eben Genmanipulationen oder was auch immer, die wissen sehr genau, dass sie alle diese Produkte, da müssen sie sich drum kümmern. Und da gibt es ein, zwei Sachen, ein, zwei Regeln so, die niemals passieren dürfen. Zum Beispiel, wenn mal irgendwie ein langfristiges Problem auftritt, was unbedingt verhindert werden muss, dass sich so Opfergruppen bilden. Also es gibt nichts Schlimmeres für ein Unternehmen, als wenn da irgendwie eine verbündete Anzahl von Opfern dasteht, die jetzt irgendwie anklagt und die irgendwie sagt, das ist schlimm oder was auch immer.
Vor allem deswegen, weil dann die Medien halt einen konzentrierten Ansprechpartner haben, die sich um diese Issue halt kümmern können.
Und also zum Beispiel, das ist ja genau eine der Sachen, die bei Shell, bei dieser Ölplattform, die von Greenpeace da besetzt wurde, sozusagen schiefgelaufen ist. Da hat es Shell also nicht geschafft, dass irgendwie dieses eigentliche Ereignis, was sie da ganz kurz halten wollten, wie ich jetzt versenkt mal kurz eine Bohrinsel, das wäre nur so gut. Das hätte mal einen Tag in der Zeitung gestanden. Shell tut was Böses, aber dann sollte es doch weg sein. Und dadurch, dass Greenpeace das eben so schön in die Länge gezogen hat, war es dann ein echtes Issue, ein echtes Problem. Und dann greifen da sozusagen die Mechanismen. Und dann geht es mit der Wissenschaft los. Also wie stellt man das Unternehmen dann positiv dar? Wie verhindert man dies? Und so weiter und so fort. Und sowas erleben wir heute in vielen Bereichen, wo eine Technologie oder eine Politik oder irgendetwas betrieben wird, was eben so Nebenwirkungen hat. Das werden wir gleich noch ein bisschen weitererläutert. Die beiden Leute, die am Telefon jetzt gerade in der Leitung hängen, bitte dranbleiben, denn erst mal kommt was anderes. Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermündung, dann 100, 1. Es ist nämlich 23.32 Uhr.
Befreiungsaktion. Nach sieben Stunden hat die Polizei am Abend eine Geiselnahme im Berliner Gefängnis Tegel unblutig beendet. Sie bewältigte den Geiselnämer, der am Nachmittag eine Justizangestellte in seine Gewalt gebracht hatte. Die Frau blieb unverletzt. Bei dem Täter handelte es sich um einen 49-jährigen verurteilten Raubmörder.
Koalitionspoker.
In Polen haben das konservative Wahlbündnis Solidarität und die liberale Freiheitsunion Verhandlungen über ein Regierungsbündnis aufgenommen. Bei den Wahlen war die Solidarität mit rund 34% der Stimmen stärkste Kraft geworden. Müllentsorgung. Nach Angaben von Greenpeace existiert ein internationales Netz zur illegalen Entsorgung von Atommüll und anderen Giften ins Mittelmeer. Daran beteiligt sind allein in Italien 26 Unternehmen. Einigung in der Serbischen Republik in Bosnien finden im Winter vorgezogene Wahlen statt. Darauf einigten sich heute Präsidentin Plavsic und das serbische Mitglied des Staatspräsidiums in Pahle, Kreisnik. Fußball in der zweiten Hauptrunde des BFB-Fokals gab es folgende Ergebnisse. VfB Stuttgart, Hertha BSC 2 zu 0, Leverkusen Hamburg 2 zu 1 nach Verlängerung, Greuther Fürth Dortmund 2 zu 4, Hannover, 1860 München 2 zu 1, Saarbrücken Kaiserslautern 0 zu 4, Neffen Stuttgarter Klotz 4 zu 1, Ulm Mainz ebenfalls 4 zu 1 und Mannheim Jena 3 zu 4 im Elfmeterschießen. Wetter Nacht 8 bis 4 Grad, morgen wieder Überwinne, überwiegend sonnig, Temperaturen bis 20 Grad. Zappsverkehr Berlin Tiergarten, die Entlastungsstraße ist zwischen der Straße des 17. Juni und Tiergartenstraße wieder frei befahrbar.
Herr Katzeheinrich, war das mit dem Fritz Kurzinfo?
Er präsentiert. Fünf-Scherne-de-Lüft. Fünf-Scherne-de-Lüft.
Jungs, das ist ein Hip-Hop-Bass.
Ein Hip-Hop-Loopas-Romant. Warte mal, ich hab ne Vision. Live in Berlin. Mittwoch, 1.
Oktober in der Weißen Rose.
Chaos Radio, der Computer Club Moon auf Rift. Jetzt gibt's kurz 2 Minuten Ninho's von Bombas.
Und dann telefoniere ich weiter zum Thema Informationskrieg.
Ich bin der Beste, der du kennst. Ich bin der Beste, der du kennst. Ich bin der Beste, der du kennst. Ich bin der Beste, der du kennst. Ich bin der Beste, der du kennst. Ich bin der Beste, der du kennst. Ich bin der Beste, der du kennst. Ich bin ein bisschen zufrieden mit der Waffe. Ich bin ein bisschen zufrieden.
Minios con Bombas.
Wo hast du die her, Tim? Gena mit Bomben. Ja, das ist irgendwie eine limitierte Ausgabe von denen. Ich kenne die Jungs, deswegen habe ich die CD trotzdem bezahlt. Wo kommen die her? Die sind aus Hamburg und das ist irgendwie ein Chile, ein Brasilianer und ein Deutscher und die machen eigentlich ganz... Ach, die sind bei Freibank.
Da muss ich mich mal drum kümmern.
Die machen irgendwie eine ganz lustige Mischung aus irgendwie Latein, amerikanischen Kram und Wild und Bangkok. So, wir reden über Informationskrieg. Hi, wer ist denn da am Telefon?
Ja, greetings, das ist der Martin.
Martin, musst du ein bisschen warten, sorry.
Okay, ich wollte eigentlich mal ansprechen und zwar interessiere ich mich da eigentlich auch für den 2. Juli 1944 und sagt euch ja hoffentlich was. Ja, also Operation Valkyrie mit Attentat auf Hitler und so und da wurden ja auch unter anderem die Rundfunkstationen besetzt und so und wo man halt, wo die Widerstandsverwalt auch die SS für genutzt hatten fieserweise und da hätte sich bestimmt auch nicht schlecht gemacht, irgendwie so ein Jammer praktisch die Rundfunkstationen, weil er trotzdem noch von einer Wolfshanze damals Informationen durchdrehen konnte. Hier sollt jetzt irgendwie nur so ein kleiner Beitrag sein, weil ich ruf eigentlich an, weil, sagt man, ist jetzt der Chaos Communication Konkret immer in Hamburg, weil ich kann mich mal erinnern, der war vor einigen Jahren irgendwann mal in Berlin gewesen.
Einmal war der in Berlin. Das war ein Experiment, das war der 10. Also wir haben da irgendwie so eine gewisse Unstimmigkeit mit den Hamburgerinnen, das ist die eine Sache, dieser Club besteht ja aus vielen Leuten, oder naja, aber schaubar vielen Leuten, aber vor allem ist es in Hamburg so, da ist das alles ein bisschen eingespielt vom Gebäude her, da verlegen sich die Kabel ein bisschen von selbst. Wir haben in Berlin im Moment keine adäquate Location für diesen Zeitraum jetzt einfach gefunden und für unsere Motivationslage. Es gibt aber womöglich im Frühjahr noch mal einen eigenen Konkurs, der ein bisschen anders heißt, den wir dann ja auch noch ankündigen werden. Das ist aber noch nicht spruchreif, also versprechen wir jetzt mal noch nix, aber möglicherweise. Es wird auf jeden Fall immer den Chaos-Kongress geben und es ist ziemlich wahrscheinlich, dass er auch noch einige Zeit weiter in Hamburg ist, aber wir hoffen natürlich hier in Berlin auch noch mal einen eigenen Punkt setzen zu können.
Genau. Ich wollte mal sagen, ich mach so eine kleine Art informellen Krieg gegen, ja im Internet praktisch gegen so eine Kinder-Pornografie-Sachen und so, SM-Sachen und zwar, ja wie soll ich das erklären, also Banner sagen wir euch ja hoffentlich was.
Einfacher ist es natürlich immer, wenn du nicht erst was sagst und dann fragst, ob wir das alle kennen, sondern dem du es einfach für die anderen am Radio erklärst.
Richtig, korrekt. Also es gibt Werbebanner, ist praktisch so, die packt man auf eine Seite und jedes Mal, so unterschiedlich wie bezahlt wird, jedes Mal wenn jemand draufklickt praktisch, dann kriegt man ein paar Fans oder so von der Firma. Von dem man halt den Warbebanner gekriegt hat. Verständlich, einigermaßen.
Ja, wir wissen ja was das ist, aber was machst du da gegen...
Ich hab wieder gerade gebeten, das zu erklären.
Ja gut, jetzt deine Anti-Kinderpornografie Kampagne.
Geht ja noch weiter, so.
Und jetzt hab ich das in Such-Engines eingetragen, gibt's ja coole Sachen, also in über 100 Such-Engines, unter so Begriffen wie, naja, Kinder-Sachen und so. Und dann klickt halt jemand, sind jetzt im Moment knapp 1000 Leute, die da draufklicken, so ne bescheuerten Leute gibt's halt, klicken drauf und dann wird halt nicht der Banner geladen, sondern gleich die Seite dazu. Und so wäre ich für einen Patienten reicher und die Leute verarsch ich praktisch mit dem U-Insatz. Ich hab ja nicht mal, wer danach sucht, ich mein selber Schuld. Also ich hab mal eine interessanter Weise bei einer Recherche von Journalisten, der sich dafür interessierte, was es denn nun tatsächlich an Hardware-Pornografien im Internet gibt, bin ich auf eine Ankündigung in diversen Sexmistgriffs gestoßen, irgendwie so halt das übliche irgendwie feuchter Server hier und da mit irgendwie mysteriöser IP-Adresse. Und dann klickte man da drauf und dann gab's halt irgendwie so richtig übelfiese Bilder von so zerquälten Versuchstieren. Halt so irgendwie auseinandergenommene Affen irgendwie bildschirmfüllend in Farbe. Hat halt auch jemand seinen Spaß gehabt.
Aber du sitzt nicht bei den Guardian Angels, oder? Martin, wir kommen mal wieder zurück zum Thema. Da sind noch ein paar Leute in der Leitung, ja?
Na und wie ist denn das eigentlich?
Ihr habt doch vor einem Monat angekündigt, dass ihr bei Ortello irgendwie Spotline mit einsteigen wolltet?
Na ja, also teilnehmen. Die haben sich meines Wissens noch nicht gemeldet. Da warten immer noch alle auf eine entsprechende Zusage. Die überlegen sich das wohl noch dreimal.
Scheiße, wollte ich auch, hat man der die nicht mitgemacht. Sag mal, jetzt...
Komm Martin, das ist keine private CCC-Quatschstunde hier. Lass uns noch die anderen ein bisschen rannehmen.
Und dann wollt ihr euch noch mal fragen...
Ach ja, verstehe. Hier kommt eine Mail. Ja genau, Tim beantwortet alle Mails immer so. Na chaos.orb.de Ah ja, richtig. Ganz einfach.
Also es ist die einfachste zu naken.
Und diese Seiten sind unter chaosradio.www.quatsch.
Ich brauche mich gar nicht mehr.
Was mich aber vorhin, ich habe einfach nur zugehört, stutzig gemacht hat, diese Klarwürdigkeit.
Was klappt man denn noch an Informationen oder was nicht?
Und da würde mich mal interessieren, was ich jetzt so mitgelegt habe.
Es wird ja auf dem Internet auch so sehr viel Quatsch angeboten.
Und was der Junge eben vor mir sagte, also man kann ja auch schön reinfliegen. Einer von Chaos Computer Club hat gesagt, er würde nur noch der Quelle glauben, die möglichst dicht am Geschehen ist.
Kann man denn das überhaupt rauskriegen, welche Quelle mich dann informiert aus dem Internet?
Es ist mit dem Internet, glaube ich, mehr noch als mit anderen Dingen, aber letztlich auch genauso. Man muss das Medium erstmal erlernen. Aber ganz anders als eben bei den klassischen Medien wie Fernsehen und Radio, die ja immer nur in die Einrichtung gehen, hast du beim Internet immer noch die Möglichkeit nachzufragen. Da hast du also sehr viel mehr in Interaktion drin. Also typischerweise, die meisten Informationen erhält man halt über das World Wide Web oder über E-Mail, vor allem über E-Mail, weil das ist einfach sehr viel persönlicher, einfach zu sprechen. Also wenn man die Leute kennt, dann vertraut man ihnen eben auf, wie man das eben auch im normalen Leben tut. Einfach so ein Vorurteil printen.
Nach und an den Antworten kannst du dazu einschöpfen.
Genau, also man kennt halt. Genauso ist es ja eigentlich auch bei euch, sag ich mal, wenn jetzt der CCC irgendwie ein Statement abgibt zu irgendeiner aktuellen Technologie, dann denkt ihr euch ja da auch irgendwas dabei, ob man jetzt dem CCC da mehr Glauben schenken kann als anderen Quellen. Also ich meine, um es nochmal kurz zu übertragen, es gab eine Geschichte im Internet, da hat mal jemand im ehemaligen Jugoslawienkrieg sozusagen ein ganz persönliches, subjektives, von ihm wahrgenommenes Tagebuch beschrieben. Und hat also berichtet, was da ganz lokal bei ihm passiert, wenn da die Menschen gestorben sind, wenn da Panzer und irgendwelche Daufeine eingeschossen haben. Also minder schöne Dinge, aber aus einer sehr persönlichen, subjektiven Sicht. Und ob man dem jetzt mehr Glauben schenkt als das, was man in den Nachrichten hört, das ist irgendwie die eine Frage, aber die andere ist, und das fand ich schon sehr deutlich an der Geschichte, dass das einen viel näheren, viel persönlicheren Eindruck vermittelt. Wenn so jemand schreibt, dass irgendwie Bekannte von ihm da irgendwie gerade mal am Sterben sind oder am Hungern sind oder irgendwelches Elendertrang, als wenn man irgendwie so ganz abstrakt in der Zeitung liest, dass da irgendwelche Leute gripieren oder dass da irgendwelche Panzer im Fernsehen irgendwie mal durchs Bild rollen und der Nachrichtensprecher dann sagt, dass da irgendwie das und das passiert. Also das Internet kann schon, das hängt aber natürlich total davon ab, wie viele und wer da sozusagen sich darum bemüht, auch Informationen hineinzupacken und nicht nur welche hinauszubekommen, weil die, die standardmäßig Informationen hineinpacken, sind natürlich gerade im www.firm.de, Werbung und was weiß ich Bescheid.
Also der Vorteil vom Internet ist halt, dass da eine Menge Informationssucher unterwegs sind, die sich halt natürlich auch in den Newsgroups und in den Mailinglisten darüber austauschen, was man jetzt von einer Information zu halten hat. Also die zuständliche Halbwertzeit von Gerüchten im Internet ist, wenn sie zu schlecht sind, nicht besonders hoch, weil halt viele Leute irgendwie versuchen, nach zu recherchieren und nachzugucken und dann halt sagen, dass es irgendwie ein Mistzweiter steht.
Also ich hab da, Petra, ich hab da auch so meinen Lieblingsbeispiel...
Ja, die Information, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist auf jeden Fall dann aktueller. Also du musst, zuerst muss es so sein, dass du ja gezielt suchst nach Informationen. Also du kannst sie uns zuschalten lassen vom Angebot, ne?
Nein, du, ja, ich mein, das ist halt... Du kannst suchen und kannst recherchieren und kannst in kürzerer Zeit rausfüdern, was dann war. Im Grunde genommen ist es ein bisschen so, das ist ja kein automatischer Dienst. Du kannst natürlich dir auch verschiedene Dienste sozusagen Informationen zustellen lassen. Ich glaub, deswegen meinte ich vorhin, das ist so subjektiv, weil im Grunde genommen funktioniert es nach einer Weile ähnlich wie in deinem Bekanntenkreis. Es gibt einfach Leute von denen, weißt du zum Beispiel, die spinnen gerne ein bisschen dazu. Und dann gibt es andere Leute, denen, wenn die sagen, ey, weiß ich nicht, guck dir den Film nicht an, also den traust du einfach, weil oft ist ja die Weitergabe von Informationen auch extrem subjektiv beeinflusst schon mal. Und so wie Andi gerade die Beispiele aufgebracht hat, ich weiß nicht, wann waren diese Riots in Los Angeles? Das kommt nämlich immer auch auf den Inhalt der Information an, weil in den Medien hieß es damals, das sind Rassenunruhen. Die Schwarzen und die Spanier gegen die Weißen. Und im Netz zum Beispiel habe ich damals viel von Leuten gelesen, die dort vor Ort leben, also wirklich Privatmenschen. Das musste ich erst mal, das glaube ich jetzt erst mal so, die jetzt gesagt haben, es geht hier nicht um Rassenunruhen, sondern es geht um Arm und Reich. Das ist das Problem und nicht Schwarz und Weiß. Und das ist natürlich eine Information, wo ich mir denke, gut, da hat ja niemand, keine staatliche Stelle jetzt Interesse daran, das zu verbreiten, sondern das scheint mir eine private Aussage zu sein. Die ist sicher auch gefärbt, nämlich von der eigenen Meinung des Schreibenden oder der Schreibenden. Aber der habe ich irgendwie mehr vertraut als dem, was ich in Nachrichten gesehen und gehört habe. Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Nichts ist wahr. Nichts ist wahr, es ist sowieso alles subjektiv.
Es gibt keine wahre Information in dem Sinne. Gibt es doch nicht.
Aber es gibt die wahre Information. Kleines Ortsspiel. Na ja, es gibt mindestens eine relativ große Auswahl von Wirklichkeiten und von Wahrheiten, aus der du auswählst.
Kommt doch drauf an, auf dem Suche bereit ich, dann bin irgendwann mal doch zu glauben.
Und prinzipiell muss man natürlich auch immer sagen, erstmal ist es durchaus gesund, alles anzuzweifeln und sich bestätigen zu lassen, nachzufragen einfach. Petra, ich sag dir erstmal. Jetzt sollte man aber einschränkend sagen, es ist gesund, da hast du recht, Johnnie, aber es ist auf Dauer natürlich auch anstrengender, das muss man schon sagen. Deswegen ist es ja, ich meine, natürlich ist es anstrengender, du brauchst Zeit dazu. Es ist natürlich leichter, ein Fahnenbein zu schalten und zu sagen, ach. Nein, ich mein, ich wollte jetzt nur nochmal kurz was aus der Soziologie einwerfen, was diese Woche im Spiegel leider falsch zitiert, weil nämlich Niklas Luhmann hat da ja noch diese Theorie immerhin eingebracht von dem Vertrauen, also Vertrauen als Komplexitätsreduktion. Weil das Problem ist ja, dass du bei einer Information irgendwie hinreichend viele Hinterfragen stellen kannst. Es gibt Leute, die sagen, Realitäten sind sowieso Schnuller. Also Realitäten sind immer verfälschte Wiedergaben von Realität, wo sich die Leute ihre eigene Rolle und den Weltuntergang eben nicht hinein meinen, sondern alles wird gut immer da implizieren. Und deswegen ist Realitätswiedergabe sowieso immer subjektive Scheiße. Und da kann man eben vertrauen und sagen, naja, es wird schon irgendwie grob hinhauen. So, wollen uns diese Handzeichen danken, Herr Pütter. Das ist leider ein NDA. Ah, wer zu spät Hallo sagt.
Und der mal putet, der kriegt nix hier.
Zeit für die nächste Zeit. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, es ist Xenia aus Berlin.
Ja, ich wollte fragen, ihr meintet doch, schlechte Gerüchte halten nicht lange, weil die Leute sehr viele nachfragen.
Wie war es denn mit diesem Penpals Brief da, der irgendwie 80 losgeschickt wurde und wo dann irgendwie zehnjähriger Junge irgendwie am Sterben lag und dann so viele E-Mail-Adressen wie möglich haben wollte, um ins Genesbruch der Rekorde zu kommen.
Das Ding läuft ja schon seit 20 Jahren oder so.
Ja, da sind wir glaube ich so, also wir kriegen ja auch beim CCC permanent externe Anfragen von wegen Ja und ich muss ja dann wichtige Daten rankommen und da ist aber leider ein Passwort und solche Geschichten, um irgendwie Informationen zu bekommen. Du meinst jetzt wahrscheinlich, dass jemand, also ich kenne den Fall jetzt nicht, ich kenne vielleicht wiederholst du noch mal kurz, was der konkrete Inhalt dieser Geschichte ist? Nein, es ging um vielleicht der besseren Verständlichkeit halber. Es ging darum, dass jemand geschrieben hat, da ist ein kleiner Junge, der liegt im Sterben und der möchte aber noch ins Guinness-Boot die Rekorde bevor er schläft. Und möchte Unterschriften haben. Und möchte so viele E-Mails wie möglich aus der ganzen Welt haben. Das habe ich aber schon jahrelang nicht mehr gesehen. Ach ich, vor kurzem auch wieder glaube ich. Das ist nicht tot zu kriegen. Da gibt es ja irgendwie so ein anderes schönes Wort, das wird nicht gleich wieder vom Thema abkommen, aber es gibt so Sachen, die werden wir nicht loswerden. Es gibt auch irgendwie Viruswarnungen, das ist auch so eine ähnliche Geschichte, ein Good Times Virus, das kriegen wir auch einmal die Woche, dass uns mal irgendjemand ein Bild schickt. Es gibt Sachen, die wollen auch gerne geglaubt werden. Es gibt so bestimmte Dinge, da ist den Leuten gar nicht klar zu machen, dass das nicht stimmt. Wir spielen Urban Legends zum Beispiel. Ja genau, das fällt dann irgendwann unter den Punkt Legenden, weil eigentlich ist es ja relativ schnell zu wissen, dass das ein Fake ist, dass es eben nicht stimmt. Das ist genauso mit diesem Good Times Virus, den kriege ich auch wirklich oft von Hörern und Hörern zugeschickt und dann antworte ich halt, es ist Quatsch, vergiss es. In dem Moment wissen die es ja, wenn man so etwas weiß. Es wissen halt viele Leute, dass es Fake ist.
Naja, aber ich meine, irgendeiner muss es ja weiter schicken und ich habe es wieder mal gehört, dass es wirklich Leute gibt, die auch wirklich dran glauben.
Kettenbriefe. Kettenbriefe. Genau das gleiche Ding, das gab es schon vor dem Internet und es wird es auch nach dem Internet geben, auch wenn es noch eine Weile hin ist. Wäre reich, mit diesem Kettenbriefe. Genau, make money fast. Also das ist nicht totzukriegen und natürlich hast du recht, also das stirbt nicht aus, weil alle wissen, dass es Quatsch ist und da wird es immer wieder, sagen wir mal, Neuankömmliche gehen, die sagen, hups, was ist das denn und darauf reagieren. Ja, aber das ist dann eine Sprache der Zeit. Die Spiegelkurve. Die Spinne in der Jukapalmer. Genau. Also ich denke, es gibt auch Informationen, da wollen die Leute auch gar nicht, dass sie fliegenden Kuh sind, selbst wenn sie falsch sind. Mit der fliegenden Kuh hast du doch sicherlich noch eine Erinnerung. Die fliegenden Kuh?
Nee, kenn ich nicht.
Also vor ein paar Monaten, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Monate gab es hier gerade im Berliner Raum, in allen Boulevard-Tageszeitungen die große Meldung, dass in Japan Leute gerettet wurden, deren Fischerboot, also Fischer, deren Boot gesunken ist, sind gerettet worden. Und die Geretteten haben dann einmütig davon berichtet, dass eine Kuh vom Himmel gefallen sei und direkt auf ihr Boot rauf. Und das Boot wäre halt daraufhin untergegangen. Und daraufhin haben sie alle diese Fischer erstmal in einer Ausnüchterungsstelle gesetzt. Dann aber auf mystischem Wege ist irgendwie ein Fax an die Medien gegangen, was angeblich von der deutschen Botschaft in Moskau nach Bonn geschickt worden sein soll, in dem ein Bericht stand, dass es russische Soldaten waren, die mit einem sozusagen entliehenden Transportflugzeug tatsächlich eine Herde Kühe geklaut haben. Und die sind dann irgendwie während des Fluges wild geworden. Und dann hatten sie halt keine andere Chance gesehen, die Klappe zu öffnen, um diese Kühe rauszuschmeißen. Und erst dann wurde also den Fischern dann wirklich geglaubt. Diese Story stand dick und fett auf Seite eins.
Und alle haben davon geredet.
Und alle waren voll unglaublich davon begeistert. Und wir haben das eben schnell mal hinterfragt. Und dachten, das kann auch alles nicht sein. Und haben eben das Internet gefragt. Und ich antworte jetzt einfach mal mit einer URL, die es im Internet gab, die hieß www.urbanlegends.com/flyingcowsinkship.html, wo also diese Geschichte so genau auch schon vor drei Jahren und wahrscheinlich auch vor sechs Jahren in anderer Form an einem anderen Ort, aber wieder eben letztlich die gleiche Geschichte wiedergegeben wurde. Also Dinge, die nicht totzukriegen sind, wohl allein schon deshalb, weil diese Geschichte einfach allen Leuten, denen ich erzählt habe, dass es ein Fake ist und dass ich klaren Beweisungen habe, die waren enttäuscht. Nein, das will ich aber gar nicht. Das ist so schön, das muss wahr sein.
Also in der alten Geschichte, die im Internet stand, war das Fischerboot nicht im Vorjapan-Sinn, auf dem Kaspischen Meer, in Russland, und die Kuh fiel aus einem amerikanischen Militärflugzeug, das Hilfsgüter transportierte. Da war eine Kuh drin und die Kuh war unruhig. Sie mussten sie rauswerfen. Die amerikanische Regierung hat dem armen Fischer laut dieser Legende ein neues Fischerboot gekauft. Die Variablen in dieser Geschichte sind so hübsch. Alleine die Tatsache, dass es angeblich ein Fax des Auswärtigen Amtes zu diesem Thema gab, hat mich natürlich veranlasst, da bei der Pressestelle anzurufen und nachzufragen, ob man da bitte mal eine Kopie dieses Faxes bekommen könnte. Aber sie wollten es mir irgendwie nicht schicken.
Das wäre natürlich auch alles ein Problem, dass der Marketingabteilung und das Zwang ist, von Medien und Zeitungen vor allen Dingen auch zu verkaufen. Denn wie die Story, dass Dolly, das geklonte Schaf, also existiert, die ist natürlich, verkauft sich viel besser als die Meldung, die es ein paar Wochen auch gab, dass das alles ganz anders war und dass man jetzt doch nicht sagen kann und so weiter und so fort. Ich hab hier schon Lorianne. Hier haben wir das Lied für Dolly. Ach so, das Lied für Dolly, okay. Wollen wir noch einen Telefon besprechen kurz, bevor wir dann das Lied für Dolly spielen? Hi, wer ist denn da?
Ja, jetzt bist du drauf.
Kannst du ein bisschen lauter? Es ist extrem leise. Kannst du ein bisschen lauter reden?
Ich würde noch mal die Kurve zurückbringen auf Informationen und so weiter mit dem Flugzeug, welches da vorne hat. Und voll mit Aufklärung für Elektronik so gewesen ist. Aber die Informationen irgendwie offenbar wirklich nicht genau genug wissend, dass Afrika schlechte Luftüberwachung hat und so weiter, nicht genau genug weitergegeben wurde offenbar. Und Flugroute und so weiter. Also ich finde es halt wundert mich, dass so bestimmte Sachen halt, dass da irgendwelche Ehefrauen mitfliegen und so weiter von der Bereitschaft und so.
Diese Namibianummer ist wirklich so dermaßen obscure. Interessanterweise, weil so Journalisten mit dir darüber gesprochen haben, meinten halt irgendwie, ja, sie kriegen das von ihren Chefredakteurinnen und Chefredakteuren gesagt, naja, interessiert doch keinen mehr. Dass diese Flugzeug aus dem O-Skype-Programm stand und da irgendwie Aufklärungselektronik drin war, die ursprünglich dazu gedacht war, im Westen zu gucken, ob die Bedingungen des Startvertrags eingehalten werden. Und es ist halt gerade kurz vor ein halbes Jahr, vorher bei der Dase, irgendwie zur elektronischen Aufpeppung war, da fragt man sich doch irgendwie, hat so ein Flugzeug mit einer Regatta-Mannschaft an Bord, irgendwie über Afrika zu suchen? Aber diese Fragen werden nicht beantwortet.
Na, die Frage hab ich gehört, die Antwort war, und ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, wer da die Antworten geben hat, aber es war in einem Live-Telefon-Interview bei Fritz, und da war die Antwort, dass diese Flugzeuge eben einfach, die müssen im Einsatz sein, die müssen geflogen werden. Und wenn es keine offiziellen gibt, dann werden die benutzt für so eine Sachen, damit die einfach weiter fliegen und so.
Damit die nicht einstauben oder so.
Voll der Erklärung. Die Frage, ob ihr darüber mehr wisst, kam übrigens auch aus dem Chat hier.
Vielleicht können wir schweben, also ich sag mal eben Thomas Deichmann, der da halt über den USA, den Lager in Ternopoli oder so durch, das Wort jetzt nicht auf dem Kopf zusammen, das ist schwierig. Da gab es wohl den britischen Nachrichtenagentur IDN oder so ähnlich, oder DNI, die halt gesagt haben, da ist ein KZ und so und dann Fotoaufnahme mit dem Stacheldraht und die Leute davor und dahinter. Das war also Wochen vorher, bevor dieses auch im Tagesspiegel hier ganz stark hochgekocht wurde, weil es hier diese Tofs zu einer FU da solidarisiert hatten. Also auch so eine politischen Information halt, so eine Sache, die Jugoslawien Politik, Großraumpolitik hier.
Ich hab ja immer so meine Theorie, und zwar vom Maff, vom momentan anvisierten Feindbild. Es gibt halt irgendwie in den deutschen Medien immer so einen Maff. Und eine Zeit lang sind es irgendwie die Kinderficker, dann ist es mal wieder die organisierte Kriminalität. Und es wird halt irgendwie immer so gesetzt, je nachdem, was halt nun gerade eigentlich an der politischen Tagesordnung ist, und was halt für Themen halt platziert werden müssen. Und irgendwie die Freie Deutsche Presse spielt halt immer so prima mit, dass man irgendwie dieselbe Thema in unterschiedlichen Variationen und Varianten irgendwie von Spiegel bis Fokus über Bildzeitungen und alle anderen Medien findet. Und da glaubt man, wenn man sich diesen Prozess eine Weile anguckt, dann nicht mehr irgendwie so sehr an...
Ja, und dann vielleicht so das Gegengewicht vielleicht so was empfehlen. Also ich glaube, es war wohl die Linie in der USA, die war halt immer konkret. Es gibt ja wohl diese leider zu seltenen Verbreite in Berlin, vielleicht noch mehr als in Westdeutscher Provinz oder so. Aber man kann sich also auch Gegenaufklärung fest besorgen, auch in Printmedien zum Beispiel.
Das geht natürlich und empfindest du aber nicht auch, also wir haben ja vorhin gesagt, dass natürlich dieses Hinterfragen oder zum Beispiel das Lesen von verschiedenen ausgerichteten Tageszeitungen, um sich einfach ein besseres Mittel vielleicht zu finden, ein Mittelmaß zu finden, das ist natürlich extrem zeitaufwendig und anstrengend. Aber man darf sich dann, ich denke mal so, dem muss man sich natürlich bewusst sein, man darf sich dann nicht beschweren. Jetzt kommt das Lied für Dolly.
Bei Bayer, Höchst, Schering, BASF, Dow Chemicals folgen sich junge gut aussehende Wissenschaftler in ihre Zellkulturen. Sie lösen das Band der Erbsubstanz der DNS, finden die Träger der vererbbaren Eigenschaften bei Tieren und Menschen, setzen diese Bausteine neu zusammen und irgendwann schenkt dann der Führer den Klonen eine Stadt.
Ja, das wundert mich ja auch immer, eigentlich ist ja nie...
Und da fehlt dann noch was, was in jedem Chaosradio, in jedem Chaos-Blumun gehört?
Kussmeldungen.
München, auf der aktuellen Oktober-CD-Rom des Computerschmuttet-Lattes Chip befanden sich zur angenehmen Überraschung der proletarischen Leserschaft auch zwei Porno-Bilder im JPEG-Format. Der Chefredakteur Rainer Grabowski schließt allerdings eine Schlamptigkeit eines Redakteurs mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit aus und vermutet einen Hacker als bösartigen Verursacher. Dieser soll, wie der Chefredakteur präzise formuliert, von außen die Bilder auf den Produktionsrechner geschoben haben. Wie das genau gelaufen sein soll und warum die Kompetenz der Redaktion nicht ausreicht, so etwas zu verhindern, wurde nicht bekannt gegeben. Das Magazin wurde indessen zurückgerufen und wird statt dem CD mit einem Gutschein ausgeliefert. Philadelphia, USA-Präsident Bill Clinton und sein Geheimdienst waren letzte Woche bei einem Besuch in Philadelphia ausnahmsweise selbst Opfer einer Abhöraktion. Ein finniger Hacker und Mitorganisator der Hacker Convention Hope, Hacker on Planet Earth, hörte konsequent Pager-Netze im heimgesuchten Bereich ab und erstellte ein umfangreiches Protokoll der Kommunikation zum Präsidenten und zwischen den Geheimdienstlern. Und in den Nachrichten waren diverse Basketballergebnisse und Hinweise auf mindere Geiselprobleme in Texas genauso zu finden wie Liebeskommunikation zwischen den Agenten. Vor allem aber zeigten die Nachrichten die genauen Stationen auf, die der Präsident auf seinem Weg zum Convention Center passierte. Pager-Netze in den USA wie in Europa weisen in der Regel keinerlei Verschlüsselungen auf. Eine neue Gesetzesinitiative der Quintenadministration möchte gerne, dass dies auch so bleibt. Overland, Kanada, Kirsten Phillips staunte nicht schlecht, als sie feststellte, dass nicht nur die regelmäßige Rentenzahlung von 860 Dollar nicht mehr eintraf, sondern auch größere Geldsummen von ihrem Konto verschwunden waren. Auch ihre Kreditkarten waren allesamt storniert. Was sie nicht wusste, war, dass sie bereits tot war. Dies behauptete jedenfalls ein Anrufer bei den Behörden und die nahmen ihn für voll, der Ernahme, Adresse und Sozialversicherungsnummer von Kirsten Phillips zur Hand hatte und sich als ihr Schwager ausgab. Der Anrufer selbst war von den Behörden nicht überprüft worden. Redmond, die allseits beliebte Firma Microsoft, hat demnächst den neuesten Segen für unsere Kleinen aus der Schublade gezogen. Nachdem sie schon vor einiger Zeit eine sogenannte interaktive Puppe des brechreizfarbenen Fernsehplüschmonds das Barney anboten, die in der Lage war, krächtend Worte von sich zu geben und limitierte Bewegungen durchzuführen, kommt jetzt der Overkill direkt aus dem Fernseher. Der Sender PBS sendet nun zusammen mit der Barney Show Steuersignale für die Puppe aus, die von einem Microsoft Set-off Box per Infrarot an die Puppe weitergeleitet werden. Der interaktive Barney hobst und krächt dann parallel zur Puppensope. Die Fensterfirma feiert sich derweil in Pressemeldungen für ihren ungeheuren Einsatz für die Weiterbildung von Kleinkindern. USA, die weltweit erfolgreiche Homebanking-Produkte stehen zunehmend in Verdacht, zu inkonsistenten Bilanzen auf dem Heimrechner zu führen. Wenn ein Heimanwender über eine längere Periode keinen Online-Kontakt zu seiner Bank pflegt, kann es passieren, dass die Bank angefallene Buchungen nicht länger vorhält, um ihren Speicherplatz zu schonen. Der Zeitraum, über den die Banken in den USA die Buchungsdaten für ihre Kunden vorhalten, sind uneinheitlich und liegen zwischen einem und drei Monaten. Die Homebanking-Software allerdings präsentiert für diesen Fall keine entsprechende Warnmeldung und pflegt die internen Bilanzen munter weiter. Nochmal USA, wie NASA, hat das Jahr 2000 Probleme in konkrete Zahlen gefasst. In intensiven Untersuchungen wird getestet, wie aktuelle im Einsatz befindliche Systeme tatsächlich mit der Jahrtausendwende klarkamen. Die Nasatechniker befanden, dass nur 19% der sogenannten Mission Critical Systeme den Millennium Test problemlos absolvierten. Die größten Probleme hatten alte Mainframe-Systeme, während Macintosh Computer überhaupt keine Probleme hatten. Aber auch Intel-PCs sind betroffen. Bisher hätten 47% der PCs den Test nicht bestanden. Das Problem liegt aber nicht beim Betriebssystem, sondern vor allem in der eingebauten Bio-Software-Rechner, die das neue Jahrtausend nicht wahrhaben wollen. Somit sind die Probleme durch einfache Softwareupdates in der Regel auch nicht zu beheben. Auch das Pentagon macht Jahr 2000 Proben. Jüngst unterzogen sie ihr Global Command and Control System GCCS, das erst im August 1990 eingeführt wurde, einem entsprechenden Test. In 10 von 28 Konfigurationen kam es zu Problemen mit auslaufenden Softwarelizenzen oder die Rechner blieben gleich vollständig stehen. In einem Fall wurden sämtliche Benutzeeinträge vollständig gelöscht. Die Verantwortung dafür wurde auf das eingesetzte Betriebssystem Solaris 2.5 abgewählt, da es bei anderen Betriebssystemen teilweise keine Probleme gab. Die Firma Sun stellte postwettend die Funktionsweise der GCCS Software infrage. Barranquilla, Colombien. Vor zwei Wochen musste der Flughafen von Barranquilla in Colombien einen Ausfall des Kommunikationssystems zwischen dem Tower und ein fliegendes Flugzeug hinnehmen. Erst nach einer Stunde konnte das Problem identifiziert und behoben werden. Eine Ratte hatte auf eine Stromversorgungsleitung uriniert und einen Kurzschluss herbeigeführt. Über den Gesundheitszustand der Ratte wurde nichts bekannt. Das war Tim mit den Kurzmeldungen. Die hat, Mestiaz wollte Bulgare, keine Ahnung, ich lass mich mal nicht... Bulgare, das ist ein sehr bemerkenswertes Projekt. Bulgares, glaub ich, sagt man richtig. Das Besondere daran ist, dass es eigentlich gar keine Chormusik gibt in der bulgarischen Volksmusik, sondern nur, in dem Projekt viele Sonosängerinnen zusammengestellt werden. Ich hab die schon zweimal live gesehen, beeindruckende Truppe von bulgarischen Muttis, die im besten Fall in der Kirche vorne stehen und einfach... Ich kann das gar nicht zusammenfassen. Dieses wunderbare, diese dissonante Klangbildung des bulgarischen, die ja einzigartig ist in Europa, trifft einen echt so toll, sollte man sich anschauen. Ja, Kinder, das ist Information, keine Desinformation, was ihr von uns kriegt. Chaos Radio, der Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Chaos Computer Club ist hier, Johnny ist hier und ihr seid da. Ihr könnt noch anrufen, wir reden über Informationskriege. Ich hab das jetzt gelernt, dass informell das falsche Wort dafür ist. Und wir haben sicher auch die eine oder andere Geschichte dazu zu erzählen, oder?
Ja, wir wollten vielleicht gerade mal über Kinderpornografie reden. Kinderpornografie war ja auch eines der angesagten Feindbilder der Medien, so von vor einigen Monaten. Überall waren Kinderpornos zu finden, Kinderficker an allen Enden, Schwanzzeiger überall auf ihrem Spielplatz zu finden. Und Anni war gerade die letzten beiden Tage auf einem Kongress der Leute, die mit dieser Historie ziemlich doll zu tun hatten. Und wollte da vielleicht noch mal zwei, drei Geschichten erzählen.
Nun gut, also es gibt eine Figur, die das Phänomen Kinderpornografie im Internet in den deutschen Medien immer wieder, also sagen, hervorgebracht hat. Diese Figur heißt Detlef Dreves. Detlef Dreves ist Leitender Redakteur der Politikredaktion der Augsburger Allgemeinen Zeitung. Das hat aber noch mal nicht so viel zu tun, sondern er hat auch ein Buch geschrieben zum Thema Pornos in den Datennetzen. Und er hat eine Menge Fälle immer wieder hervorgebracht. Er ist sozusagen in den Datennetzen unterwegs, insbesondere in den Online-Diensten. Und irgendwie werden ihm da immer wieder Kinderpornos angeboten. Es gab einen Fall, da wurden ihm sogar Kinder selbst angeboten, inklusiv Entsorgung der Kadaver. Das war der relativ berühmte Fall in Rosenheim, weil nachdem dann die entsprechenden... Also das ging ja auch groß durch die Presse und dann war noch Haus zu suchen und alles Mögliche stellte sich denn heraus. Es war alles ein klein bisschen anders, weil im Datennetz, im T-Online oder im Chat ist das alles gar nicht gelaufen, sondern im Chat hatte er explizit noch irgendwie so Geschichten gefragt. Dann bekam er eine Telepronummer und in einem Telefongespräch wurden ihm nachdem er explizit danach gefragt hatte, so machen sie sowas auch, dann auf Schleswig diese Dienstleistung angeboten. Die Hausbezugung hat aber nur ergeben, dass diese Leute ein Salomaso-Studio in ihrem Keller hatten und ein Salomaso-Studio ist nun irgendwie nicht wirklich verboten. Der Trick war der, ich war also auf einer Tagung in Düsseldorf gerade der Kinderschutzzentren Deutschland. Kurze Zwischenfrage, also A, muss man immer dazu sagen, ihr seid über viele Sachen sehr informiert. Deswegen muss man vielleicht für andere Leute jetzt sagen, dass es natürlich nicht darum geht zu behaupten, das gibt es alles nicht, sondern darum geht, die Geschichten, die da auftauchen, zu entlaufen. Genau, es geht jetzt insbesondere um, was da eigentlich die Bestandsaufnahme ist. Und diese Tagung hatte eben auch, die war organisiert von den Kinderschutzzentren. Und da waren unter anderem auch Leute von den Landeskriminalämtern aus Rheinland-Pfalz, aus Bayern, aus Nordrhein-Westfalen und so weiter geladen, um also über Erfahrungen zu richten. Das ging auch darum, dass die Kinderschutzzentren zunächst einmal eine Bestandsaufnahme haben wollten. Wie schlimm ist es denn? Was ist denn dagegen zu tun? Sind die Datennetze denn wirklich überhaupt nicht zu kontrollieren? Und so weiter und so fort. Also ich kann das jetzt schlecht mit dem, was an zwei Tagen alles diskutiert wurde, in zwei Sätzen bilanzieren. Aber um grob sozusagen zu versuchen. Es hat sich ein bisschen herausgestellt, dass wir hier ein Phänomen haben, was nicht so schrecklich viel mit Datennetzten zu tun haben. Also Kindesnissbrauch, sondern sicherlich, wenn Kinder nicht im Internet nissbrauchen, sondern im wirklichen Leben. Und das Internet dient, wie Videokassetten, auch natürlich als Medium für bestimmte Leute, um sowas auszutauschen. Aber insbesondere die vielen Medienmeldungen, die eben dieser Dilett Brevis dadurch, dass er eben immer wieder im Chats danach gefragt hat, ihm Sachen angeboten wurden, er dann eben Testerklärungen rausgegeben hat, die Polizei informiert hat und so fort. Also dieser Mann ist da einfach, der taucht da immer wieder auf. Und es ist ja jetzt zunächst mal ihm nicht zu unterstellen, wenn er als engagierter Mensch sich da um dieses Problem kümmert und darauf auch aufmerksam macht. Das Komische war nur, ich hab dann da auch einen Vortrag halten können. Mein Thema lautet, das ging ein bisschen in eine andere Richtung. Medienkompetenz, also wie können dann solche Organisationen wie Kinderschutzvereinigung sich sinnvoll eines Mediums wie das Internet bedienen, um vielleicht auch ganz offensiv mal sowas zu diskutieren, um auch anonyme Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten für missbrauchte Kinder zur Verfügung zu stellen, damit die eben da berichten können und so fort. Nicht nur große Hemmschwellen haben wir im wirklichen Leben, wo sie irgendwie ihre Väter da anzeigen müssen, aber das auch immer. Und ich hatte im Rahmen dessen auch nur einen ganz kurzen Punkt mehr oder weniger auf einem meiner Folien, der lautet so Realanteilermittlung von aufgenommenen Informationen. Also Medienkompetenz heißt ja, kompetent mit dem Medium umgehen, sozusagen lesen im Netz. Heißt auch immer, sich darüber klar werden, dass das eventuell auch viele Informationen sind oder was auch immer. Und da hatte ich das ermittelt. Das ist im Grunde auch das Thema Überwendung. Und dann fragte mich eine etwas ältere Frau von so einem Kinderschutzverein eben, also die sagte, ihr würde das auch eine Menge Sorgen machen, dass sie sozusagen den Medien nicht mehr trauen kann. Was für Erfahrungen wir denn da hätten oder ob ich da noch mal ein bisschen konkret darauf eingehen könnte. Und ich sagte eben, ich will das jetzt mal an einem Beispiel machen. Der Herr Dreeves ist ja auch hier im Raum oder auch nicht. Ich wusste das nicht genau am zweiten Tag, ob der noch da war. Er war irgendwie nicht da. Der Dirk Dreeves ist mir das erste Mal begegnet sozusagen in einer DPA-Meldung. Eine DPA-Meldung, die besagte, dass im Internet laut dem Internet-Experten Dirk Dreeves 50 Millionen Seiten kinderpornografischen Inhalt seien. Ich hab daraufhin, war ich zufällig, den Professorleiter bei DPA für die Computergeschichten da kannte, ihn angerufen und hab gesagt, im Internet gibt es laut Alta Vista, laut dieser großen Suchmaschine, gerade mal insgesamt zu dem Zeitpunkt 20 Millionen Seiten.
Und wie sollen, nee, zu dem Zeitpunkt waren es 20.
Und ich dachte, wie sollen von 20 Millionen Seiten 50 Millionen kinderpornografischen Inhalt sein? Irgendwie druckt ihr da einen Scheiß. Und er sagte, also die hat eigentlich geschrieben in Meldungen, die haben dann eine sogenannte Zusammenfassung geschickt. Also Korrekturen gibt es ja nicht bei Presseagenturen, weil die ja niemals das Falsches rausschicken, sondern das heißt dann Zusammenfassung ist auch egal.
Jedenfalls wurde das dann korrigiert.
Ich erzählte also auf der Tagung kurz diese Geschichte von dieser Pressemeldung und dass ich also den Detlef Grevis danach auch in Diskussion mit anderen Leuten und mit den Meldungen, die da kamen, eigentlich nur als Agent Provokateur verrechtigte. Also dass das offenbar jemand ist, der da ein Thema hochbauscht, der da unseriös die Fakten durcheinanderwirbelt und irgendwelche Geschichten berichtet und also irgendwie, dass das eben komisch ist. Und das war alles nur ein Beispiel, um deutlich zu machen, wie vorsichtig man sein muss mit so Sachen, die man da hört. Und nach meinem Vortrag, nachdem mir dann noch ein paar andere Sachen kamen, kam da so ein etwas älterer Herr auf mich zu, so ein ganz gepflegter Typ mit irgendwie Jacke und Schlips und Hagen und weißen Haaren, ein bisschen älter wie er, und dachte, er hätte das ja alles sehr interessant gefunden. Und insbesondere hätten wir da offenbar einen gemeinsamen Verdacht, dass der Herr Greves da als Agent-Provokateur ist. Dann gab er mir seine Visitenkarte, der war also vom Bayerischen Landeskriminalamt. Und ich dachte so, ich habe jetzt von allen möglichen erwartet, da irgendwie einen Zuspruch zu bekommen, aber nicht gerade vom Bayerischen Landeskriminalamt, weil ich dachte eigentlich eher, sie sind so eine Institution, die solche Leute bezahlen, um so zu sagen als Agent-Provokateur da zu sein. Und dann meinte er, nein, es ist nicht so, dass wir sowas nicht könnten, aber wenn, dann machen wir das selbst. Und bezahlen da nicht irgendwie irgendwelche Dilettanten. Also lange siele kurzer Sinn, er hat mir ganz offen gesagt, und es hat auch anderen gesagt, dass also der Herr Treves unter Beobachtung steht. Das ist kein formelles Ermittlungsverfahren. Damit wartet man ab, bis man genug zusammen hat. Aber er hat offenbar einige Geschichten, die er auch an die Polizei und an die Presse weitergeleitet hat. So Dialoge, Chat-Dialoge, in dem ihm Kinder, Pornos und Kinder zu Vergewaltigungen angeboten seien, die hatte er offenbar wichtig. So drückte er sich auch selbst geschrieben. Außerdem hätte man Beweise, dass er, dass der Herr Dresde selbst kinapornografisches Material verbreitet hätte und so weiter. Er haute schon ziemlich rein, das erzählt der Polizist da. Der vom Landeskriminalbealte. Beim Bayerischen LKA gibt es keine eigene Teilung, die für Internet und Online-Dienstüberwachung tätig ist. Aber gut, das ist jetzt eine relativ schöne Geschichte. Ich habe mich dann auch mit ihm unterhalten, warum denn, was da macht denn sowas?
Ist das jetzt der Verfassungsschutz oder wer oder wie?
Und dann meinte er, dass er da eher an gewisse politische Kreise denkt, die halt ein Interesse dran haben, hier nach der großen Keule Staat zu schreien oder was auch immer, um das Internet eben besser zu kontrollieren oder zu regulieren. Es ist natürlich auch viel einfacher, bei der Bevölkerung eine Regulierung eines neuen Mediums durchzusetzen, wenn man Sachen hat, die sehr sensible Themen sind. Also es ist natürlich klar, wenn du eine Meinungsumfrage machst oder eine Volksabstimmung und sagst, sind wir auch dafür, dass Kinderpornografie verboten wird? Beziehungsweise ist ja verboten, also überhaupt nicht die Diskussion. Und man kriegt natürlich über diese Themen die Masse ganz schnell, diese sensiblen Themen. Also nicht nur das, man kriegt vor allem auch die Exekutive. Es gibt diesen schönen Fall mit diesem Anonymizer-System da in Finnland. Erinnert sich ja sicherlich noch dran, wo es sein Toilet-Dreamer eben den Laden dicht gemacht hat, indem sie ihm einfach mal vorgeworfen haben, er hätte halt pornografisches Material in der Internetverbreitung. Es war natürlich nichts dran. Aber lief halt erstmal so auf der Welt. Man kann wirklich, also da möchte ich dann schon auch noch mal auf das Thema Radio zurückkommen. Da kann man sich ein bisschen was anlesen, was die Geschichte des Radios in Deutschland auch angeht. Denn auch da hat man wirklich lange versucht, das politisch alles zu regulieren. Also man würde auch heute bestimmt gerne noch Radio regulieren und mehr auf den Inhalt den Finger drauf haben. Und das ist, wenn man sich in die Situation eines, einer Regierung versetzt, natürlich auch durchaus nachvollziehbar. Wenn du die Medien kontrollierst, dann ist eine ganze Menge mehr Einfluss auf deinen Tenfold. Jetzt kommt unser Lied. Unser Lied für Marianne. Für all die verlorenen Herzen da draußen. Und die wir auch immer denken. Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1. Das wird nicht schön.
Nordirland Konferenz. Dabei wurde am Abend in Belfast ein wichtiger Fortschritt erzielt. Man einigte sich auf der Grundlage eines von Großbritannien und Irland vorgelegten Papiers über einen Autonomiestatus für Nordirland zu verhandeln. Befreiungsaktion. Nach sieben Stunden hat die Polizei am Abend eine Geiselnahme im Gefängnis Berlin-Tegel unblutig beendet. Sie bewältigte den Geiselnäher, der eine Justizangestellte in seine Gewalt gebracht hatte. Die Frau blieb unverletzt. Bei dem Täter handelte es sich um einen 49-jährigen verurteilten Raubmörder. Koalitionspoker. In Polen haben das konservative Wahlbündnis Solidarität und die liberale Freiheitsunion Verhandlungen über ein Regierungsbündnis aufgenommen. Bei den Wahlen war die Solidarität mit rund 34 Prozent der Stimmen stärkste Kraft geworden. Müllentsorgung. Nach Angaben von Greenpeace existiert ein internationales Netz zur illegalen Entsorgung von Artürm, Müll und anderen Gesten ins Mittelmeer. Daran beteiligt sind allein in Italien 26 Unternehmen. Fußball in der zweiten Hauptrunde des DFB-Pokals gab es folgende Ergebnisse. VfB Stuttgart, Hertha BSC 2 zu 0, Leverkusen Hamburg 2 zu 1 nach Verlängerung, Gräuter führt Dortmund 2 zu 4, Hannover, 1860 München 2 zu 1, Saarbrücken, Kaiserslautern 0 zu 4, Meppen, Stuttgarter Kicker 4 zu 1, Ulm, Mainz ebenfalls 4 zu 1 und Mannheim, Jena 3 zu 4 im Elfmeterschießen. Nachts 8 bis 4 Grad am Tage wieder überwiegend sonnig, Temperaturen bis 20 Grad. Keine aktuellen Meldungen, wir wünschen euch gute Fahrt.
Ja, ich auch. Geil, heute heimlich.
Fritz präsentiert Choco-Troni Zwei mal nacheinander und live in Berlin. Donnerstag, 25.
Dezember und Freitag, 26.
Dezember und immer im Kesselhaus. Für diese Konzerte gibt es keinen Vorverkauf, sondern Karten nur an der Abendkarte.
Wir bitten um rechtzeitiges Schlange stehen.
TopoTronik, live in Berlin, präsentiert von...
Was immer das aufwirklich ist, The Briem Food of Asher, es war ein schönes Konzert.
Am Montag war Corner Shop im Sendesaal.
Das SFB für mich ein bisschen fehl platziert, weil da möchte man sich doch zu bewegen. Und im Sitzen ja bekanntlich schwieriger.
Die Tinder-Sticks danach, dann allerdings mit einem wirklich großartigen Konzert. Das ist dann schön, wenn man da sitzen kann und schön zuhören kann und einen guten Sound hat. Mehr Musik in dieser Richtung, sicher ab 1 Uhr. Und so hat man es schon noch. Cornershop, die Band sitzt danach am T-Shirt-Stand und verkauft die eigenen Platten und die eigenen T-Shirts. Dann kann man noch ein paar nette Sätze mit der Bandwechsel, das ist doch Ziel am Kunden. Im Chat wird grad verlangt, den Trailer nochmal zu spielen. Kinder, den müsst ihr immer gleich zuhören.
Ich störe nicht den Trailer jetzt nochmal.
Tocotronic morgen und übermorgen im Kesselhaus, ne? Das glaub ich. Oder? Was im Kesselhaus?
Donnerstag, 25.
Dezember und Freitag, 26. Dezember und immer im Kesselhaus.
Genau und immer im Kesselhaus Freitag.
Morgen und übermorgen im Kesselhaus, Tocotronic mit ganz viel Anstellen wahrscheinlich und mit, sich mit kleinen Mädchen rumprügeln müssen um die Karten. Mit allen Worten, ich geh ja nicht hin, das ist mir zu anstrengend. Genau, wir haben fast bekommen ein Fax von Microsoft Copyright PC Fax an Fax, was immer das heißen mag. Nein, tatsächlich ist es von einem Joachim. Und du bist wohl der Mensch, der bei uns mal was gewonnen hat.
Vor zwei Jahren, ne?
Ist alles schon eine Weile her. Wir erinnern uns. Du warst derjenige, der als erstes die DTMF Töne, die wir irgendwie übers Radio gespielt haben, herausfand und dann die richtige Telefonnummer, die das dann darstellte, anrief und sozusagen hier als Erster ankam. Nein, du bist sogar so ehrlich und behauptest, du wärst der Zweite gewesen. Wir wissen genauso wenig wie du, was wir dir damals als Preis tatsächlich versprochen hatten, aber um die Sache aus der Welt zu bringen, sollst du bekommen ein original Chaos Computer Club Alt plus F4 T-Shirt, sozusagen unser offizielles Club-Shirt. Seine Adresse haben wir ja und so wird dann endlich alles gut.
Du hast dann also in etwa dreieinhalb Jahren dein T-Shirt.
Wir waren eigentlich das Treffen auf der Funkausstellung. Waren da Fritzhörer auch? Hat da eine Fritzhörerin geredet, die auch in der Sendung kam? Nein, also überhaupt war das recht nerdfrei. Also diese IFA war auch so dermaßen unglaublich schlimm, dass es einfach die Filifrix angezogen hat. Ich war nicht einmal da. Das wollte ich jetzt damit praktisch sagen. Der Flipstand war ja auch richtig langweilig. Ich war nicht einmal da. Hey, das ist viel flott, hat sich nur die Beine in den Bauch gestanden und war so angeödet. Naja, die Position des Steins war auch nicht gerade so glücklich. Irgendwo in der Ecke, ein bisschen an die Seite geschoben. Das ist ja auch immer keine Entscheidung von Fritz. Die haben auch nicht unter anderem eine finanzielle Entscheidung, ob sie den Funk ausstellen.
Was kommt denn der Quadratmeter?
Die mögen diesen Sender. Wenn ihr sagt, diesen Sender mögt ihr nicht, dann sagt er, das war die letzte Sendung. Natürlich mögen die nicht, dass die uns mal anrufen würden und sagen, die mögen uns. Die mögen euch auch. Die sind nur schüchtern, ich weiß. Nein, die sind nicht schüchtern. Aber man kriegt hier nie gesagt, dass irgendetwas gut ist. Aber wenn irgendetwas schlecht ist, dann melden sie sich schon. Insofern braucht ihr euch keine Sorgen machen, solange keiner bei euch anruft. Also ich gehe auch immer nach dem Prinzip. Hervorragend. Wobei sie öfter anrufen.
Aber in welchen anderen Sachen?
So, kommen wir jetzt noch mal auf unseren Themenkreis zurück oder sind wir jetzt schon wieder in der Ausgangsphase? Wir sind schon ein bisschen in der Chill-Out-Area wieder. Frank sitzt dann wie beständig am Chat. Frank. Frank, wann schneidest du dir die Zoppeln hinten ab? Tja, das ist die Frage. Dabei hatten wir eigentlich nicht jemand, zu dem Frank sich auch äußern musste. Also wir haben ja jetzt ein bisschen über Information und hier und da geredet und es gibt natürlich noch so verwandte Abarten der Informationshändling. Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand von euch Streit um Asterix kennt, dieses wunderbare Comic, wo es eine Figur namens Tullius Destructivos gibt. Überall wo der ist, gibt es dann Streit. Da verfärben sich dann auch diese Sprechblasen, also grün mit der roten Buchstabe und die Leute fangen alle an sich anzuschreien. Also sowas gibt es natürlich auch als Taktik. Das nennt sich dann Zersetzung. Das Ministerium für Staatssicherheit hat dazu eigene Schulungen durchgemacht, wie man also Gruppen zersetzt und so fort. Wir kennen das aus eigener Erfahrung. Da gab es natürlich auch schon mal so, wenn man sich so nicht so richtig ganz beliebt macht bei bestimmten staatlichen Stellen, dann passieren da auch komische Dinge, kommen irgendwelche Leute an und da werfen sich zum Beispiel gegenseitig vor, man würde für den Verfassungsschutz arbeiten, was super ist in so einer kleinen Gruppe mehr oder weniger, weil im Zweifelsfall da gibt es dann zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder derjenige, dem vorgeworfen wird, er würde für den Verfassungsschutz arbeiten, arbeitet tatsächlich für den Verfassungsschutz oder aber derjenige, der das Gerücht hier reinbringt, der also den Vorwurf haben will, das könnte ja auch sein, dass der für den Verfassungsschutz arbeitet, um sozusagen eben so einen Zersetzungsprozess in Gang zu setzen. Das kann man sich dann wunderbar gegenseitig vorwerfen und so weiter und fort. Bei dir hatte ich auch immer schon den Eindruck, du arbeitest für den Verfassungsschutz. Ja, also ich gehe bei dir immer den Eindruck an.
Was ungefähr dasselbe wie der Verfassungsschutz ist.
Dabei hatte ich bei Franke mal den Eindruck, ja, man würde gerne den Verfassungsschutz haben, aber das machen wir dann gleich im Auto.
Ich meine, wenn Jungs lesen, ob sie bei ihren Zeitschriften Ausschnittabteilung irgendwie Public machen wollen, dann könnte ich ja echt damit leben. Also diese Zersetzungsnummer ist halt so eine Sache, die hat die Stasi ziemlich gut dokumentiert hinterlassen, zum Glück, so dass man sich da mal einen Eindruck machen konnte, wieso Geheimdienste in diesem Bereich arbeiten. Prinzipiell beruht es darauf, dass sie durch Verbreitung von ausgewählten Waren, teilweise Waren, teilweise falschen und komplett falschen Informationen versuchen, Gruppen-Dynamik-Strukturen zu schaffen, die dazu führen, dass muslimische Gruppen sich zerspalten oder sich in kleinen Kriegen um die Hierarchiefolge oder wer dann nur der Boss ist, oder ob man ihm stehen oder im Sitzen pinkeln soll, halt irgendwie zerfieben haben. Und das führt ja dann halt doch ziemlich oft zum Erfolg. Also wenn sie halt einen persönlich so richtig nicht mochten, dann konnte das schon mal passieren, dass man halt morgens irgendwie einen Haufen Kies vor der Haustür fand, oder halt irgendwie tatsächlich einfach Unannehmlichkeiten im persönlichen Leben hatte, bis hin zum Verlust von irgendwie hohen Wohnungen. Und die Zersetzung in Gruppenstrukturen ist interessanterweise einer der wenigen Punkte, die halt in der GAUK-Behörde nur so mäßig dokumentiert wird. Es war ja im Strasi-Unterlagen-Gesetz gibt es eine Passage, dass bestimmte Unterlagen, die die Arbeitsweise von Nachrichtendiensten betreffen, vom Innenministerium vorher entsorgt werden durften, bevor die GAUK-Behörde ihre Finger auf die Unterlagen legen konnte. Und da waren auch unsere anderen Zersetzungsgeschichten dabei.
Womit wir wieder auf ein Thema Verschwörungstheorien wären. Da hat man auch schon mal eine eigene Sinne. Was sind denn eigentlich die kommenden Themen jetzt? Also ich denke die Diskussion über das Sitz- oder Stehpinseln, die müssen wir offenbar echt nochmal führen. Also ich denke ja eigentlich ist es keine Diskussion, dass man sich hinsetzt.
Also Sitzpisser sind echt Agenten, es gibt keine Diskussion drum.
Ich erzähl euch jetzt mal einen schönen Witz zu dem Thema. Auf Witze erzählen im Radio ist eigentlich ein ganz großes Nein, aber ich hab's angekündigt, deswegen will ich es jetzt tun. Gott steht vor Adam und Eva. Und hat einen kleinen Beutel in der Hand und sagt, ich hab hier noch ein paar Sachen übrig, die könnt ihr nicht mehr unterbringen bei der Schöpfung. Da könnt ihr euch jetzt aussuchen, wer das haben will.
Ich guck mal hier, was hier im Sack ist.
Ach, was haben wir denn da im Stehen pinkeln können? Und Adam schreit, ja Gott, ich will's haben. Oh Gott, bitte, ich im Stehen pinkeln können.
Oh ja, ich will's, ich will's.
Und Gott sagt, okay, Adam, hier hast du's im Stehen pinkeln können. Ja, hast du's. Und Adam probiert's aus und super. Oh, danke Gott, super. Und Gott sagt, so, was hab ich denn hier noch? Ach ja, multiple Orgasmen.
Na, Kinder, so viel zum Thema große Klappe.
Und zum Thema im Stehen pinkeln. Können wir mal das Personal hier wie ein Grundverwaltungsfähig sein?
Ich stelle mir doch lieber auf die Verschwörung. Ich würde das noch mal in der Falle sagen.
Um aber zu zeigen, dass Tim auch eigentlich ein ganz sensibler Charakter ist.
Also eigentlich haben wir schon einen Plan.
Warte gleich, ich wollte erst noch deinen Turnspiel hier.
Ah, hallo. Eicher. Da Eicher drauf? Tatsächlich, siehst du?
Grauzone, Text Eicher.
Schönes, analoge Zeug, ne? Und Klappen klingen auch viel besser, Graz. Mittlerweile glaub ich der. Du wirst wissen, was nächstes Mal Chaosradio ist. Nächstes Mal haben wir ein tolles Thema. Und zwar heißt das dann Science Fiction Reality Check. Und wir wollen mal klassische Science Fiction Literatur, aber auch bekannte Science Fiction Filme auf ihre Visionen hin abklappern, die sie so in Aussicht gestellt haben, inwieweit die sich denn nun tatsächlich erfüllt oder nicht erfüllt haben. Das betrifft sowohl technische Dinge, die dort beschrieben werden, Luvern zum Beispiel, oder eben auch alles, was dazugekommen ist, und auch die gesellschaftlichen Visionen, die diese Werke sozusagen in Aussicht gestellt haben. 1984 ist da sicherlich das bekannteste Thema, was auch immer wieder diskutiert wird, aber vieles wie Lämmen oder so wird eben nicht so sehr diskutiert, und das kommt dann eben in der nächsten Sendung, also eine sehr lyrische, politische, gedankenvolle Sendung sein wird.
Wir haben einen Karten, der hat 3.000 Zanzibchen-Romane bisher gelesen.
Er war auch noch nicht hier. Was ganz schön wäre, ist, dass wir die Sendung auf jeden Fall so ein paar Textpassagen anführen. Wir werden zitieren, wir werden nur Musik spielen aus den Filmen, soweit wir es schaffen. Der Pablo wird dann nächstes Mal dabei sein, der war bisher noch nicht dabei. Für den November haben wir, glaube ich, dann wieder ein hardcore-technisches Thema auf dem Programm. Das ist die taktische Waffen-Prozessoren-Kunde. Dort wollen wir mal so ein bisschen den Maschinen unter die Haube gucken und mal gucken, was jenseits von Intel noch alles so auf diesem Planeten lebt. Da kann ich nicht, glaube ich. Und für den Dezember haben wir natürlich wie immer kein Thema, weil die Dezember-Sendung traditionell ausfällt. Da wäre da alle auf dem Chaos-Kongress. Wäre ja vielleicht mal zu überlegen, ob wir das dann vielleicht doch schaffen, dass Fritz dann noch mal vom Chaos-Kongress berichtet. Wäre nicht schön, eine Sendung live von da zu machen, vielleicht auch mit Publikum. Zwischen den Radiosendungen, damit es nicht langweilig wird, findet ihr Informationen zwischendurch auch auf www.ccc.de oder könnt auch ein Probeexemplar klar unserer Zeitschrift Datenspreuder euch zum Beispiel gegen 5 Mark Rückporto anfordern beim CCC in der Schwenkestraße 85 in 2025 in Hamburg. Und wenn ihr Anregungen, Ideen oder was auch immer jetzt im Kontext zu diesen oder zukünftigen Radiosendungen habt, dann schickt uns entweder eine Mail an www.chaosradio.ccc.de oder schickt uns, hab ich doch gesagt. Ohne BWC gesagt. Ohne BWC www.ccc.de Es gibt auch eine E-Mail-Adresse deineseite.ccc.de. Hier sagt jemand TSEC hat angeblich schon mal irgendwas geschickt? Passiert da mit was? Ja, eine Regelpakete auf der Seite. Ich erinnere mich an einen, den ich gerade noch nicht drauf gesetzt hatte. Aus Gründen, die mir nicht ganz klar sind. Ich glaube, das war irgendeine lustige Grafik mit einem Inhalt, den ich jetzt nicht ganz erinnere. Das kommt auch noch drauf. Das soll ein Sammelsurium sein, alles dessen, was Chaosradio-Freunde meinen, das dort erscheinen sollte. Das werden wir ganz wertfrei da einfach so publishen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Form von Hörerbeteiligung wirklich populär ist, aber es ist schon mal was gekommen.
Ich probiere es ja auf meinen Seiten auch.
Das ist extrem schwierig. Jeder kann ja im Prinzip auch seinen Kram selber machen. Ich habe neulich darüber mit ein paar Freunden geredet. Und das Erstaunliche ist wirklich, dass es scheint zu sein, dass Kreativität immer am meisten dann freigesetzt wird, wenn es eigentlich ganz wenig Mittel gibt. Je weniger man hat, desto mehr scheint Kreativität hervorzukommen. Wenn man Rechner zu Hause hat, mit dem man schreiben, malen, Ton aufnehmen kann, Video bearbeiten kann, wenn mit kleinen Quickcams diese durchaus super 8 Kameras ersetzen könnten und sogar noch günstiger sind, kann man lustige Filmchen mit seinen Stofftieren drehen oder keine Ahnung. Da kommt es doch sehr wenig.
Dann muss man einfach einen ASCII-Art-Contest machen. Ach, die sind sehr unwaglich.
Na, wir haben ja irgendwann einen Contest. Das können wir vielleicht nochmal kurz erwähnen. Es gibt ja auch immer noch den Trailer-Contest, obwohl wir schon einige gekriegt haben. Einige?
Na ja, eigentlich...
Einen und dann diese ZIP-Drive, die wir jetzt haben, von der wir noch nicht wissen, was drauf ist. Für einen Trailer, WETSASAPES TO SPIEL, finde ich. Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, bisher ist noch nichts dabei gewesen, was nicht so richtig ist. Die ZIP haben wir noch nicht gehört.
Eben. Die ZIP haben wir noch nicht gehört. Die ZIP wäre der Hammer. Schauen wir mal, wie das so ist.
Wir hatten ja auch heute wieder mal so ein CD laufen von jemanden. Das war auch sehr schön.
Habt ihr gesehen, da kann man es gerade zu tun? Gibt es demnächst ja auch eine neue Datenschleuder.
Genau, die ist gerade ganz frisch. Ich bin jetzt gerade in dem Moment, die durch die Rotation läuft. Also wer immer schon mal Datenschleuder lesen wollte und sich da ein Probeabholen sollte, jetzt wäre eine gute Gelegenheit, eine top aktuelle Ausgabe zu erhalten.
Wir haben auch interessante Team-Gifte.
Vorletzte dieses Jahr.
Zum Beispiel haben wir dieses Mal das Thema D-Box-Hacking.
Genau, eine schöne Bastelanleitung, was man mit seiner digitalen Zettelbox noch alles so schönes machen kann, außer nur Fernsehen zu empfangen. Ansonsten sollte man vielleicht im Bereich technische Informationen kurz dazu sagen, dass ohne dafür Sabon machen zu wollen, aber dass die Rufumleitung bei der Zweifelzeit noch umsonst ist.
Wie?
Bis März oder so machen die so einen Versuch. Kannst du ins Festnetz umsonst umleiten.
Also für Leute, die irgendwie zum Beispiel noch eine 90 Nummer haben oder so, könnte das interessant werden. Die haben uns aber glaube ich geblockt, ne? Vielleicht.
Vielleicht nächste Woche erst. Ich denke jetzt nach dem Ticker, den Ticker, den Ticker, den Ticker. Chaosradio Ticker, die Meldingsliste, wo wir immer Informationen posten. Ich werde diesmal zum Beispiel auch unsere Kurzmeldungen da mal draufjagen mit den passenden URLs zum Beispiel auch zu dieser Meldung mit den USA-Präsidenten. Also da gibt es wunderbare URLs, wo die kompletten Pager-Protokolle abgedruckt sind, was also dann nun tatsächlich irgendwie über den Ether gegangen ist und von diesem Hacker mitgeschnitten wurde und andere Dinge. Geht alles mit den Ticker und wir freuen uns sehr darüber, dass wir jetzt schon über 500 Leute auf der Verteilerliste drauf haben. Ja, das sind so, dieses Feedback ist extrem wichtig. Also man merkt daran in dieser Sendung, dass das noch eine Weile braucht. Ich meine, wir sind einmal im Monat, das ist natürlich auch nicht so viel, aber es braucht eine Weile, bis sich Sachen rumsprechen, aber ich glaube inzwischen haben wir so einen ganz guten Stamm von Leuten dabei. Das macht uns sehr freut natürlich.
Also wir wollen auch versuchen, in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten den Ticker ein bisschen heftiger zu benutzen und da halt auch noch ein paar mehr Nachrichten drüber zu bringen als nur einmal im Monat die Kurzmeldung, aber da wird sich noch Entwicklung geben.
Nichts ist wahr, aber alles wird gut. Das war Chaosradio bei Fritz Gleisig und Martin Petersdorf für den Night Flight. Und bis dahin, Friede auf Erden und eine gute Gesinnung für jedermann.
Das ist eine knappe Minute nach eins.